MORNING IN RESPONSE TO COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCIES AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING. AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE BORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
A MINUTE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INTO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY. TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT DIVERTISSEMENT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AN AXIS COLD
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN. AGAIN
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY THE
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. AN OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU WILL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
MUTED ON MUTED HAND. ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM TO THE BEST OF
MY ABILITY DURING THE HEARING
AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHY EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT. OUR HEARINGS.
HOUSING PASS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTSWHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE. OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD-
THIS IS OUR FIRST. HEARING OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TODAY
WE HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA THROUGH WHICH ARE. ITEMS
FOR CONSENT SB SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AS P. ONE A ONE
BUT SENATOR NELSON AND S. B. TO
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR LEYVA.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS
THEM- ON THE BILLS WE MUST
FIRST ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BRADFORD HERE BRADFORD HERO
CHOI BOGUE. THE TROUBLE CARE
SKINNER. SKINNER HERE WIENER. A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISH.
BEFORE WE CAN START WE MUST
APPROVE COMMITTEE RULES AS
STATED THIS IS OUR FIRST TIME
FOR THE YEAR SO YOU ALL SHOULD
HAVE RECEIVED A COPY OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES AS YOUR MOTION
FOR THE ADOPTION TO COMMITTEE
RULES. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SCANNER. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS COMMITTEE RULES BE
ADOPTED BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD I'D A CHOKE HI JOBO
GUYS SCANNER. SKINNER AYE
WIENER. THE ROCKET. SIR. YES
WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL
FOR SOONER MAKING WINNER. OKAY
WHEN WE HAVE OUR FIRST. AUTHOR
HERE I BELIEVE I SHOULD ZERO
SOMEWHERE SOONER TAKE MATH.
SENATE EGGMAN OF IF YOU'RE
READY WE'RE READY FOR SB THREE
TWENTY WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING AND IT IS A IT IS MY
HONOR TO PRESENT MY VERY FIRST
BILL IN THE SENATE THIS
MORNING- TODAY I AM PRESENTING
SB THREE TWENTY A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO BETTER PROTECT
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC ABUSE
FROM GUN VIOLENCE. SB THREE
TWENTY ACCOMPLISHES THIS BY.
ONE CODIFYING CALIFORNIA RULE
OF COURT FIVE POINT FOUR NINE
FIVE WHICH CREATED A JUDICIAL
OVERSIGHT PROCESS TO ENSURE
FIRE ARMS THAT HAVE BECOME
PROHIBITED. AS A RESULT OF A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER ARE
ACTUALLY RELINQUISHED AT THE
EARLY SOME OF THE POSSIBLE. AND
TO IT REQUIRES THE COURT TO
COMMUNICATE THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABOUT FAILURES TO
RELINQUISH THESE WEAPONS WHICH
WILL ASSIST IN PREVENTING.
ANGELI DEADLY ESCALATION OF GUN
VIOLENCE IN ALREADY VOLATILE
SITUATIONS IN CALIFORNIA 33% OF
WOMEN AND 72% 27% OF MEN
EXPERIENCE SOME FORM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DURING THEIR
LIFETIME. WE KNOW THAT THE
PRESENCE OF A FIREARM IN THE
HOME AND DURING AN INCIDENT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCREASES THE
RISK OF HOMICIDE BY AT LEAST
5100% EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT WOMEN
OF COLOR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. BY FIREARM RELATED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. EVEN WITH
THE STATE'S ROBUST
COMPREHENSIVE BYRON LEGISLATION
RECOVERING PROHIBITED FIREARMS
IS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT. AND
DATA FROM THE ARMED PROHIBITED
PERSON SYSTEM SHOWS THAT THERE
ARE OVER TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA. WHOARE
PROHIBITED BUT WHO HAVE FAILED
TO RELINQUISH THEIR WEAPONS AND
KEEP IN MIND THIS IS ONLY THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE REGISTERED GUNS.
BECAUSE THE RULE OF COURT SB
THREE TWENTY IS CODIFYING HAS
BEEN OPTIONAL. OVERSIGHT A
FIREARM RELINQUISHMENT IN THE
CIVIL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CONTEXT
IS INCONSISTENT ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE BURDEN OFTEN
FALLS ON THE SURVIVOR TO
REQUEST THAT THE COURT APPLY
ITS OWN ROLE. AND CONFIRM THAT
PROHIBITED FIRE ARMS HAVE BEEN
RELINQUISHED. WE KNOW BETWEEN
SIXTY AND 90% OF FAMILY LAW
LITIGANTS ARE SELF REPRESENTED.
AND HAVE TO NAVIGATE THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM BY THEMSELVES.
SB THREE TWENTY ACKNOWLEDGES
THIS FACT AND MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT THE BEST ENTITY TO STEP IN
AND MAKE SURE FIRE ARMS OR
RELINQUISHED. AT THE EARLIEST
POSSIBLE MOMENT IS THE COURT. I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH US
TODAY. THE FIRST IS JULIA WEBER
THE IMPLEMENTATION DIRECTOR
GIFFORDS LAW CENTER 2% PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE WHO ARE ALSO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND
ALISON CAP PART THE DIRECTOR OF
LEGAL SERVICES THAT WE'VE WHO
IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER PROCESS. WHEN
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I. US
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS ACTUALLY
PUTTING A PART IN PLACE A
PROCESS TO ACTUALLY. PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN HAVE A RESTRAINING
ORDER AND HAVE A WEAPON ARE
SUPPOSED TO RELINQUISH IT.
DOESN'T USUALLY HAPPEN. SO
WE'RE PROVIDING A PROCESS FOR
THAT FOR THE COURT TO DO THAT
AND ALSO TO COMMUNICATE TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IF THAT
HAS NOT BEEN DONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR GRAHAM YOUR FIRST
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF YOUR YOUR
WEBER ARE YOU PREPARED TO
TESTIFY AT THIS POINT. I AM
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO HEAR
ARGUMENT CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME.
OKAY GREAT GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JULIA
WEBER I THE IMPLEMENTATION
DIRECTOR AT DIFFERENT LAW
CENTER TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
SPONSOR OF SB THREE TWENTY. I'M
AN ATTORNEY IN SAN FRANCISCO
EACH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHY
GOLDEN GATE UNIVERSITY AND I
SERVE AS AN EXPERT WITNESS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES. I'M
APPEARING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
GIFFORD. I'VE WORKED IN THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FIELD FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
INCLUDING SEVENTEEN YEARS WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WHERE I
WORKED ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
CHILD CUSTODY. INCLUDING
DEVELOPING RULES SUCH AS THE
ONE SB THREE TWENTY IS BASED
ON. I'VE ALSO WORKED WITH POST
ON TRADING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND ON PROMISING PRACTICES FOR
IMPLEMENTING FIREARM
PROHIBITIONS. SB THREE TWENTY
WILL ELEVATE THE IMPORTANT ROLE%
OUR COURTS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITIES PLAY IN ENHANCING
PUBLIC SAFETY IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITUATIONS. IT WILL
HELP INSURE THOSE WHO ARE
PROHIBITED FROM HAVING FIREARMS
WILL RELINQUISH THEM AS CLOSE
TO THE TIME OF PROHIBITION AS
POSSIBLE. CHALDEA JAY'S ARMS
PROHIBITED PERSONS LEGISLATIVE
REPORT HAS CONSISTENTLY
RECOMMENDED THAT CALIFORNIA
IMPLEMENTED PROHIBITION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHEN THEY ARE
IMPOSED MOST RECENTLY THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
FOCUSED ON THE INTERSECTION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND FIREARMS.
AS AN AREA IN NEED OF
IMPROVEMENT STATEWIDE IN CIVIL
RESTRAINING ORDER PROCEEDINGS
WERE MOSTLY BEGINS ARE
REPRESENTING THEMSELVES IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT SURVIVORS BRING
INFORMATION ABOUT FIREARMS TO
THE COURT'S ATTENTION RECEIVE
THE PROTECTION THE LAW
PROVIDES. INCLUDING REDUCING
FIRE ARMS RISKS WHICH IS WHY
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ENACTED
THE RULE OF COURT INITIALLY.
FOR THESE PROHIBITIONS TO BE
EFFECTIVE RESTRAINT PARTIES
NEED TO BE GIVEN LOCAL
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO COMPLY
TO INCREASE SAFETY FOR EVERYONE
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE PUBLIC. I SENATOR AG IS
NOTED THE PRESENCE OF FIREARMS
IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SITUATIONS
INCREASES THE RISK OF LETHAL
OUTCOMES FOR FEMALE INTIMATE
PARTNER VICTIMS BY 5100% MORE
THAN ONE MILLION WOMEN ALIVE
TODAY HAVE BEEN SHOT OR SHOT AT
BY AN INTIMATE PARTNER AND THIS
DOESN'T BEGIN TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE MANY WAYS FIREARMS ARE USED
TO COURSE OF WE CONTROL
PARTNERS. WELL WE HAVE
STATEWIDE COURT FORMS THAT
EXPLAIN TO RESTRAIN PARTIES HOW
THEY CAN COMPLY WE DON'T YET
HAVE PROTOCOLS THAT MAKE THESE
LAWS MOST AFFECTED BY ENSURING
THE PERSON WHO MUST RELINQUISH
FIREARMS ACTUALLY DOES SO. SB
THREE TWENTY WILL CHANGE THAT
AND PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AGENCIES. TO BE
INCLUDED IN THIS KEY COMPONENT
OF RISK REDUCTION. THESE ARE
TRUSTED PEOPLE WHO CAN HELP
SUPPORT COMPLIANCE. WHEN
INDIVIDUALS DON'T COMPLY WITH
CIVIL RESTRAINING ORDER FIREARM
PROHIBITIONS LAW ALREADY
PROVIDES FOR CRIMINAL
SANCTIONS. BUT BECAUSE THESE
ARE CIVIL CASES TOO OFTEN THIS
INFORMATION IS NOT PROVIDED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT CREATING
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS THAT COULD OTHERWISE
BE AVOIDED. SB THREE TWENTY
WILL CHANGE THAT AND BECAUSE
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT AND
LIFE SAVING POLICY WE URGE YOU
TO VOTE AYE AND SB THREE
TWENTY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS WEBB WHO WERE UP.
WHOEVER I'M SORRY HI ALISON
GEPHARDT. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALICE AND
CAPARO I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
LEGAL SERVICES WITH WEEDS I
AGAIN I THINK VIOLENCE AND
CRACKLE ABOUT SERVICES AGENCY
IN SACRAMENTO I AM ALSO A
PRACTICING FAMILY LAW ATTORNEY
I THINK PROVIDE A STAFF OF
THREE OTHER THAN A LOT OF
TURNING. I DIRECT- BUT WE'VE
BEEN TEACHING COMPONENT
SERVICES FOR VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AT IN THEIR
FAMILY LIKE READINGS INCLUDING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS. WE'VE SUPPORT SB THREE
TWENTY AS IT WILL IMPROVE THE
SAFETY OF VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WHO ARE SEEKING
PROTECTION FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR CHILDREN VIA FAMILY COURT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCERESTRAINING
ORDER PROCEEDING WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL IMPROVE
SAFETY FOR MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS A RESULT OF THE
COMMUNICATION. THAT WILL HAPPEN
BETWEEN THE FAMILY COURT AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. IF THE
COMMITTEE HAS ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE DVR-
PROCESS AND HOW IT IMPACTS
SURVIVORS I'M HAPPY TO TRY TO
ADDRESS. THANK YOU. DON'T MISS
MODERATE REMOVING TO ANY
WITNESSES AND- THE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND TWENTY FORTY.
TOUCH OF WISHING TO FIND
SUPPORT C. NINE MOVING NOW TO
OUR PHONE LINE DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS- WITH THIS IS IN Q. OR-
WANTING TO TESTIFY. ON S. P.
THREE TWENTY THREE TWENTY I'M
SORRY. SMALL RARE THERE THE
CHAIRMAN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A- COMMENT. ON SB
THREE TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE ALL AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH MY NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU MISSED IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT ON AS- THE
THREE TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. YEAH MY
MOMMA MISTER CHAIR. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE TO ENOUGH
FOR SB THREE TWENTY MISTER
CHAIRMAN Q. AND I FEEL TO
ANSWER THEIR ANY WITNESSES AND-
HERE IN. WRONG FORTY TWO ALL
THREE IN THE GALLERY SCENE NINE-
RIGHT MOVING TO OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWENTY.
C. NINE IN ROOM TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY ARE THERE ANY AT TWENTY
FORTY. SHE NINE PRESIDENT.
THERE ARE NONE HERE AND FORTY
TWO ALL THREE IN OUR GALLERY.
MISTER MODERATOR CAN WE MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN Q. IN OPPOSITION
TO SB. THIRTY TWENTY. THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND LEAD INTO MANY PEOPLE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. AT THE TIME OF
THE TIME AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU I BRING YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEES OR ANY
QUESTIONS ON IN REGARDS TO SB
THREE TWENTY. BY ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SANDERS CAN-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRED- BUSY
EGGMAN- RESHAPE YOUR BRAIN THIS
BILL AND APOLOGIES IF I DIDN'T
CATCH THIS YOU MAY PRESENTED IN
YOUR OPENING BUT- COULD YOU- DO
YOU HAVE THE STATS ON. THE.
EITHER THE LIKELIHOOD OF DYING
AT THE HANDS OF AN INTIMATE
PARTNER FOR IT OR SOME OTHER
STATS THAT WOULD INDICATE WHY
IT IS SO ESSENTIAL TO- TO MAKE
SURE THAT FIREARMS ARE
RETRIEVED FROM THESE A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE- I DON'T HAVE THE
OVERALL STASHED WE KNOW IF
THERE'S A GUN IN THE HOUSE IT
INCREASES THE CHANCE BY 5100%
BY 10% IF A GUN IS IT BUT FOR
THE FOR THE- THE PERSON WHO HAS
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ASSAULT
AT. RESTRAINING ORDER BUT THAT
ALSO DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO OFTENTIMES
ARE HARMED BY THESE WEAPONS
STAYING IN THE HANDS WE HAD AN-
EXAMPLE OF THAT. TWO YEARS AGO
IN SACRAMENTO WHEN SOMEBODY HAD
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER THEY WERE ON THE
PROHIBITED PERSONS LAST WHEN
THE POLICE SHOWED UP AN OFFICER
WAS SHOT AND KILLED AT THAT
TIME- I DON'T HAVE THE-
APPRECIATE THAT INFO I DON'T
HAVE THAT- DATA DIRECTLY IN
FRONT OF ME BUT- IT'S ACTUALLY.
ARE QUITE SIGNIFICANT-
ESPECIALLY AMONGST WOMEN- OF.
THE WOMAN'S. DEATH IS. IT LIKE
DISPROPORTIONATELY. LIKELY TO
BE AS A RESULT OF AN INTIMATE
PARTNER MURDER. THEN THAN ANY
OTHER. AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ALSO
HAS HIGH INCIDENCE OF ON. FIVE
THE WEAPON DISCHARGED NOT FROM
THEM SO MUCH BUT FROM THEIR
INTERVENTIONS IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASES IT'S QUITE
DANGEROUS EVEN FOR OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS SO I
THINK THIS IS A VERY NECESSARY
BILL AND REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING FORWARD AND WANT OTHER
FOLKS ABOUT THEIR QUESTIONS-
CHAIR I'M WILLING TO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS. NINETEEN
NINE. SENATOR AGAIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD JUST
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
VERY COMMONSENSE MEASURE TO GET
THE GUNS OUT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE THEM AND I
DON'T HAVE ALREADY PROVED
THEMSELVES TO BE AT RISK OF
HARMING A POTENTIALLY KILLING
OTHERS- AND HANDED THE VICTIM
SHOULD NOT BE THE ONE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OBTAINING THAT
WEAPON WE PUT IT IN THE HANDS
OF THE COURT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB THREE TWENTY. I'M
A- SINNER SKINNER. YES I MOVED
THE BILL CENTER SKINNER HAS.
PROBABLY MOVED SB THREE TWENTY.
WE HAVE A MOTION. MADAMS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SB THREE TOTAL TWENTY EIGHT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. EDWARD R.
BRADFORD AYE THE TROUBLE BOGUE.
CHOTO GUYS SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO THE VOTERS
FOUR ZERO THAT MEASURES OUT
CONGRADULATIONS INTERACTING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH Q. MOVING
TO SB SIXTEEN CENTER SKINNER
ARE YOU PREPARED TO. PRESENT
YOUR MEASURE AT THIS TIME. I AM.
AB WALDRON RIGHT YEAH FOR. ALSO
ARE YOU CONCERNED. YOU CAN YES
ARE WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON
CONSENT CAN WE GET A MOTION FOR
APPROVAL OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT ITEMS. THE SENT ITEMS-
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD AYE CHAU
BOTH. THE TROUBLE GUY SKINNER
AYE SKINNER AYE WIENER. WIENER
I'D FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO ON THE
CONSENT THAT MEASURES DISPENSED
WITH NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
OPEN UP THE ROLE ON. ON THE
RULES APPROVAL OF THE COMMITTEE
RULES AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS WIENER. WIENER
AYE FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO FAT
MEASURES CONCERTS DISPENSE WOOD
NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK TO SB
SIXTEEN CENTER SKINNER WHEN
YOU'RE PREPARED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- YOUR CHAIR AND- MEMBERS
S. B. C. SORRY SB SIXTEEN. IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF MY BILL LAST
YEAR SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX WHICH
MADE IT ON THE FLOOR OF THE
ASSEMBLY WITH A FIFTY FOUR
VOTES I BELIEVE. AND BUT DUE TO
IT BEING THE END OF SESSION AND
A HARD STOP MIDNIGHT DEADLINE.
AND BILLS HAVING A DELAY
GETTING FROM THE ASSEMBLY TO
THE SENATE IT NEVER REACHED THE
SENATE FLOOR SO WE WERE UNABLE
TO VOTE ON IT- WILD ONE CANNOT
WHY COULD NOT A SEARCH WITH
ALL. BUT- HE COMPLETED- S.
CERTAINTY THAT IT WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN A SIMILAR RESPONSE ON
THE SENATE FLOOR I FEEL THAT-
GIVEN THE VOTE IN THE ASSEMBLY
IT LIKELY WHATEVER- NOW
INDEPENDENT OF THAT WE'VE GOT
IT BEFORE US TODAY. SO WHAT S.
B. SIXTEEN DOES IS IT EXPANDS
UPON THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BILL
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WHICH I
AUTHORED IN WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED. AND THAT BILL
WAS THE FIRST TIME IN OVER
FORTY YEARS THAT CALIFORNIA
OPENED UP TO PUBLIC ACCESS.
RECORDS AROUND CERTAIN TYPES OF
POLICE MISCONDUCT NOW WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS THEY HAVE THE MOST
IMPORTANT JOB AMONGST MANY OF
OUR PUBLIC SERVANTS. AND THEIR
ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOB IS
BASED ON COMMUNITY TRUST. WHEN
THE COMMUNITY DOES NOT FEEL
TRUSTFUL OVERCONFIDENT ABOUT
THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
AND THEY WILL NOT PARTICIPATE
IN FOR EXAMPLE BEING WILLING TO
BE A WITNESS TO A CRIME
REPORTING A CRIME OR ANY NUMBER
OF THINGS. SO IT IS REALLY
ESSENTIAL TO BUILD THE
COMMUNITY TRUST. AND
TRANSPARENCY OR SUNSHINE
ASSISTS US IN DOING SO AND TO
HAVE OVER FORTY YEARS OF
BASICALLY NO ABILITY FOR THE
PUBLIC TO GET ACCESS TO RECORDS
ON POLICE MISCONDUCT WAS REALLY
A TRAVESTY AND WHEN WE LOOK
ACROSS THE US. IT WE WERE AN
OUT LIAR NOW THAT BILL WAS VERY
IMPORTANT WAS GOOD BUT IT WAS
VERY VERY LIMITED AND WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS BAD TO OUR ABILITY
TO GET THAT PUBLIC INFORMATION
AND I WILL ADD THAT OUR- PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT WHICH AFFECTS EVERY
OTHER. PUBLIC EMPLOYEE GIVES
MUCH MUCH MORE RECORDS IN INFO
SO WHAT IS SIXTEEN SPECIFICALLY
DO IT ADDS TO CURRENT LAW BY
ALLOWING. US TO GET RECORDS ON.
FORCE THAT- I'M REASONABLE.
THAT IS BEYOND JUST SHOOTING OF
A WEAPON SO THERE'S A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT- UNREASONABLE
FORCE IT ALSO ALLOWS US TO GET
RECORDS ON OFFICERS WHO HAVE A-
DEMONSTRATED. BIASED OR
DISCRIMINATORY BEHAVIOR.
OFFICERS WHO HAVE ENGAGED IN
UNLAWFUL ARRESTS AND SEARCHES.
OFFICES WHO HAVE ENGAGED IN
CERTAIN DISHONESTY SUCH AS
FRAMING PEOPLE. AND IT
ADDITIONALLY REQUIRES THAT.
WHEN AN OFFICER LEAVES AN
AGENCY IF AN INVESTIGATION AND
NOT A COMPLAINT ON THAT
OFFICERS NOT COMPLETED THE
RECORD IS STILL MAINTAINED. AND
IF THE OFFICER REPLIES TO
ANOTHER AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA
THAT AGENCY MUST REQUEST ALL
PERSONAL RECORDS AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT IS THAT WE
HAVE SEEN. THAT SOME AGENCIES
OR OFFICERS HAVE TRIED TO GET
AWAY WITH NOT HAVING A RECORD
ESTABLISHED BY JUST LEAVING
THEIR AGENCY QUITTING. BEFORE
AN INVESTIGATION WAS COMPLETE
NOW FINALLY WHAT THE BILL DOES
IS AFTER FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
PASSED. WE FOUND THAT MANY
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE WERE
VERY COOPERATIVE RELEASED
RECORDS UPON REQUEST BUT MANY
OTHERS DRAGGED THEIR FEET AND
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF LOCALITIES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. THAT TO
THIS DAY. STILL RELEASED EITHER
NO RECORDS OR VERY FEW RECORDS
UNDER SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY. IN FIVE.
THE COUNTRY TO THE PURPOSE OF
THE LAW SO WHAT TIS BILL DOES
IS PUT A TIME CERTAIN ON THE
RELEASE OF RECORDS AND ALSO
SOME PENALTIES. TO THE
JURISDICTIONS FOR DRAGGING
THEIR FEET AS AN INCENTIVE FOR
THEM TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW.
NOW WITH THE VERY ORIGINAL BILL
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WAS HARD
FOUGHT OUR POLICE UNIONS IN
ALMOST ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OPPOSED IT. HOWEVER IN THIS
CASE WE HAVE. ON THERE. THERE
REALLY IN BETTER CERTAIN. IN
THAT OUR POLICE OFFICER GENE
FOR EXAMPLE PORAC IS NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL OUR HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS ARE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL THE POLICE CHIEF STILL
HAVE A PROBLEM THE SHARE OF
STILL HAVE A PROBLEM BUT I
THINK THE- OVER RIDING. PUBLIC
INTEREST IN THIS ACTION SHOULD-
SHOULD RECOMMEND ARE.
PROCEEDING AND THEN I HAVE A
COUPLE OF GREAT WITNESSES
NATASHA MINSKER- A LAWYER WHO
HAS WORKED ON BILLS IN THIS.
TAX TYPE AND THEN I ALSO HAVE
SHEEPISH JOHNSON KNOWN AS UNCLE
BOBBY WHO IS THE UNCLE OF OSCAR
GRANT AND HE CAN RELATE HOW HIS
FAMILY WAS ABLE TO FINALLY GET
RECORDS. AND UNDERSTAND THE
FULL EXTENT OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE SHOOTING OF A OSCAR GRANT
THAT NIGHT THAT NEW YEAR'S EVE
NIGHT AT THE FRUITVALE BART
STATION AND WITH THAT I'LL ASK
FOR THE WITNESSES. THANK YOU AS
STATED WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES- SPENCER ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TESTIFY THIS TIME.
YES GOOD MORNING THIS IS
NATASHA MINSKER SPEAKING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA. SB SIXTEEN IS A
MODEST BILL THAT SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THE COMMON ROADBLOCKS
THAT FAMILY MEMBERS AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HAVE ENCOUNTERED.
IN TRYING TO ACCESS POLICE
MISCONDUCT RECORDS UNDER UNDER
SKINNER'S PREVIOUS BILL SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE SH FOR MORE
THAN FORTY YEARS. ALL RECORD OF
POLICE MISCONDUCT WITH HIDDEN
FROM THE PUBLIC. SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE RESTORED THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO KNOW ABOUT
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT BY POLICE AS
IT BECAME LAW FAMILY MEMBERS
RECORDERS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WORKS HARD TO GET ACCESS TO
THOSE RECORDS ENCOUNTERED MANY
ROADBLOCKS. MANY RECORDS WERE
PURCHASED AS LEGAL UNDER
EXISTING LAW. RECORD PRODUCTION
WAS DELAYED FOR MONTHS EVEN
MORE THAN A YEAR BECAUSE THERE
IS NO EFFECTIVE MEANS OF
FORCING TIMELY PRODUCTION OF
THE RECORDS UNDER CURRENT LAW.
SHAMLI MEMBERS WERE CHARGED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
FOR QUOTE COPYING. RECORDS THAT
ARE MAINTAINED IN DIGITAL
FORMAT AND THAT CAN BE
REPRODUCED WITH A FEW STROKES
OF THE CANE. AN ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE WAS ASSERTED TO BLOCK
ACCESS TO BASIC FACTS. AND
WITNESS STATEMENTS. SB SIXTEEN
REMOVED THESE ROADBLOCKS AND
MAKE MEANINGFUL THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHT OF ACCESS TO SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT INFORMATION. WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT IN
PASSING SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE.
SB SIXTEEN WILL ALSO PROVIDE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO SUSTAINED
FINDINGS OF MISCONDUCT THAT
RELATE TO THE INTEGRITY AND
FAIRNESS OF POLICING.
SPECIFICALLY SIXTEEN PROVIDES
PUBLIC ACCESS TO SUSTAINED
FINDINGS OF YOUTH FORCE TO
SUSTAINED FINDINGS OF UNLAWFUL
ARREST OR SEARCH AND TO SUSTAIN
FINDINGS OF DISCRIMINATION FOR
ACTIVE PROJECTS BY POLICE.
THESE KINDS OF MISCONDUCT
UNDERMINE OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE PUBLIC HAS
A RIGHT TO KNOW THAT THEY'RE
BEING TAKEN SERIOUSLY BY THEIR
LOCAL DEPARTMENT. FINALLY I'M
ALSO EXPRESSING SUPPORT TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA. WE URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON SB SIXTEEN A
MODEST BILL TO PROMOTE THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS MICHAEL BOBBY.
SURFACE JOHNSON. BOB THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AS AN
IMPACT A FAMILY MEMBER TODAY I
AM SEEKING JOHNSON AFFECTS THE
KNOWN AS UNCLE BOBBY AT THE
UNCLE OF OSCAR GRANT I AM THE
CO FOUNDER OF CALIFORNIA
FOUNDED UNITED CONGESTIVE AND
CO FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL
FAMILY UNITED CONGESTION. I
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR POLICE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR TWELVE YEARS THAT THE
MURDER OF MY NEPHEW OPT GRANT.
WHEN SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
BECAME LAW ON JANUARY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. IT TOOK
ANOTHER SIX MONTHS GOING BACK
AND FORTH TO COURT JUST TO GET
THE RIGHT TO GET SOME OF THE
AND BUT IN A PILE OF THE MURDER
COSTS THE GRANT. AND RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY. THANK YOU EDIE
Sí
RECORD BUT I'M STILL TRYING TO
GET. AFTER THE MURDER ON JAN
FIRST TWO THOUSAND NINE OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS
HAVE BEEN KILLED BY THE POLICE
IN THE STATE. CALIFORNIANS THE
MOST DEADLY A STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY. KALAMKARI CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW LACKS TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY LAWS WOULD
RESULT IN POLICE KILLING FAR
MORE PEOPLE THAN IS NECESSARY
LEAVING FAR TOO MANY FAMILIES
DEVASTATED AND COMMUNITY HELLO
THANK. IN THIS MOMENT OF
RECKONING IT IS CRITICAL THAT
WE SPEND OF THE HUMANITY AND
DIGNITY OF THOSE IMPACTED BY
POLICE VIOLENCE UNDER
UNDERSTANDING IF THE CULTURAL
POLICEMEN THAT MUST BE CHANGED.
POLICE CONTRABAND HOW THEY
INTERACT WITH DEFENCE STAND
COUNTER WHETHER TO ISSUE A
WARNING OR MAKE AROUND. HOW
THEY RESPOND TO A FLEEING
SUSPECT HOW THEY RIDE AN ARREST
REPORT TO JUSTIFY THIRD ACTION
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY WILL
LIE UNDER OATH. WE MUST NOT LET
THIS MOMENT PASS WITHOUT
SWEEPING. TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. ATION THAT
PROTECT THE RIGHTS STAVING MY
LIFE. POLICE AGREE THAT THE-
CULTURE POLICING. SET UP
INFORMAL CULTURAL NORMS THAT
ARE UNIQUE TO THE OCCUPATION OF
POLICING IS THE MOST. IMPORTANT
DOCUMENTS OF POLICE BEHAVIOR.
SB SIXTEEN BUT CHANGE THE
CULTURE OF POLICEMEN. AND OUR
CALLS BUT THAT. NO HARM COMPARE
TO WITNESSING LOVED ONE BE A
MURDER BY THE POLICE IT IS.
ETCHED IN YOUR MEMORY BECAUSE
IT COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED.
POWER THE POLICE TO USE DEADLY
FORCE IS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITY WE CAN GIVE ANY
PUBLIC SERVANT. EVERYONE
RESPONSIBILITY MUST BE GUIDED
BY COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION THAT
PROTECT HUMAN LIFE. SAVE HIM
AND PROTECT HUMAN LIFE RIGHT M.
SAVE HIM A LIGHT. SB SIXTEEN
WHAT CHANGED THEIR CULTURAL
POLICING AND HELP SAVE AND
PROTECT HUMAN RIGHTS THE LIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR MOVING
TO WITNESSES HERE IN FORTY TWO
OLD THREE- SHE NO WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERIES OR ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIXTEEN.
SINGING NINE HERE WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO ROOM TO FORTY.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIXTEEN ROOM
TO FORTY. JEAN NINE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MATTER RAIDER DO WE HAVE. ANY
WITNESSES IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTEEN WOULD PRESS ONE
ZERO. IT WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW. AND MY MOM IS A GERMAN. Y.
NUMBER THIRTY NINE THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING DONNA THANKS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR KING TELLS HOW MANY
CALLS WE HAVE BEEN CUTE AND
SUPPORT. YES SIR WE HAVE ELEVEN
IN Q. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN LINE NUMBER THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DENIS CUEVAS ROMERO
REPRESENTING THE- ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR THIS. BY NUMBER THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS THIS IS DIANA COVERED
ARE NOW ON THE APP OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR THIS. MY NUMBER THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS. MY
NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SO
HE HAS TO LEAVE HIS JOB ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND WE WERE PLEASED TO BE CO
SPONSORS OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE AND WE ARE. KILEY. SIXTEEN
TO. BY NUMBER TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MARCO GEORGE ON THE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
THIS. PART NUMBER FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE NUMBERS THIS IS
MERRY HIGHER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY- SITTING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS. BY
NUMBER TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS THIS IS
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BY NUMBER FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
BREAKING FAR STUDY I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT SIXTEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND
NUMBER FORTY SIX THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH.
NUMBER FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES GOOD MORNING THIS IS
TRACY ROSENBERG CALLING FROM
OAKLAND PRIVATELY IN SUPPORT OF
THE XP SIXTEEN THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER FORTY ONE THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
TENDENCY ON BEHALF OF U. A. W.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE AND
FIFTY EIGHT TEN PER PRESENTING
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND WORKERS
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. Q. AT THE TIME OF
THE TERM AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. K.
WHO ARE MOVING NOW TO
OPPOSITION. I SEE WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
JONATHON FELDMAN AND COREY
ALESIS SO THE HOLLOW- IS MR
FELDMAN PREPARED AT THIS TIME
FOR HIS TWO MINUTE TEST IN. YES
SIR CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
CORRECT. I THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS JONATHAN FELDMAN WITH
OUR STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION APERSONA THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THEIR COMMITMENT TO
TRANSPARENCY A COMMITMENT THE
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
SHARES. THE ONLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATION TO
SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL BILL SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE ACTOR YOU
LOBBY FOR THE PASSAGE OF THE
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE CLOSED AT
THE SIXTEEN- CLEARLY NOT
BECAUSE POLICE YOU STILL TO THE
BENEFIT RELEASING THIS
INFORMATION. BUT RATHER DUE TO
THE FACT THAT THE PRACTICAL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL
WILL OVERWHELM AGENCIES.
COUPLED WITH THE STRICT
TIMELINES IN CIVIL PENALTIES SB
SIX. MINUTES PALATABLE FOR
FAILURE. SB SIXTEEN EXPAND WHAT
IS RELEASABLE TO INCLUDE
SEVERAL NEW CATEGORIES
INCLUDING ALL FILES RELATED TO
END OF THIS CALL A CALL FROM
THE BILL AN INCIDENT INVOLVING
THE USE OF FORCE TO MAKE A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC COMPLY
WITH AN OFFICER. TO CLARIFY-
BUT WHAT A PREVIOUS SPEAKER
SAID IT IS ALL FILED BY JUST
THE PAIN WHEN IT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE USE OF FORCE
THIS IS UNFOUNDED AND
UNDERSTAND AS WELL- IS A BROAD
AND BIG EXPANSION THAT WILL
APPLY TO MANY MANY INCIDENTS
UNFORTUNATELY. I WE LOOK AT THE
CONTEXT AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AND APPLIED
TO THIS WHERE AGENCIES WERE
INUNDATED WITH REQUESTS
SOMETIMES DUPLICATIVE REQUESTS
ASKING FOR ALL THE FILES
RELEASABLE UNDER THE NEW
STATUTES. AND THERE'S NO REASON.
TO EXPECT ANYTHING DIFFERENT
THE NEXT TIME. WE ANTICIPATE-
THE SIGNIFICANT. ON YOU KNOW
THESE FILES ARE SOMETIMES
HUNDREDS OF PAGES ALONG REQUIRE
HOURS AND HOURS OF STAFF TIME
AND LEGAL REVIEW PREPARE IN
ORDER TO COMPLY WITH PRIVACY
LAWS. AGENCIES DEDICATED FULL
TIME STAFF MAJOR RESOURCES TO
MEET THE DEMANDS OF FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE WHICH WAS
DRAMATICALLY MORE NARROW THEM
SB SIXTEEN. AND I WAS AT THE
TIME LOCAL GOVERNMENT WASN'T
STRUGGLING WITH THE FINANCIAL
DOWNFALL. GLOBAL PANDEMIC. I
SIXTEEN INCLUDE THE CIVIL
PENALTIES FOR AGENCIES THAT
DON'T MEET THE SIX MONTH
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION DATE-
WELL WE DO APPRECIATE THE
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION WHICH
WAS SOMETHING WE ASK FOR LAST
YEAR. SIX MONTH IS INSUFFICIENT
GIVEN THE MASSIVE NEW
REQUIREMENT. THAT YOU SIXTEEN
ALSO REQUIRED THESE RECORDS ARE
HELD INDEFINITELY AND TO PUT
THAT INTO CONTEXT AGENCIES PAY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS STORAGE. UNDER EXISTING
FIVE YOUR ATTENTION CALLED THE-
OTHER A DRAMATIC EXPANSION.
FINALLY AT SIXTEEN- ALTHOUGH
NOT IN IN THE BILL ITSELF BUT
PART OF THE PRIOR STATUTE IN SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE. STILL
ALLOWS AN OFFICER WHO IS THE
SUBJECT OF AN INVESTIGATION TO
REQUEST THEIR OWN FILE DURING
THAT ACTIVE INVESTIGATION. I
WHICH WE HAVE EXAMPLES OF
TAKING PLACE. WHICH IS AN
UNINTENDED ERROR IN THE STATUTE
BUT THAT WILL ONLY CONTINUE TO
UNDERMINE JUSTICE IF WE EXPAND
THE STATUE WITHOUT TAKING THIS
CALL. THIS IS AN ISSUE WE
BROUGHT UP IN OUR CONVERSATION
SOMETHING WE HOPE TO RESOLVE
THIS YEAR. ULTIMATELY AS OUR
RECORD SHOWS THE POLICE CHIEF
SUPPORT TRANSPARENCY AND HAVE
APPRECIATED THE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WE HAVE WIT THE
AUTHOR. WE HOPE TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS WITH FEATURES
AMENDMENTS BUT UNTIL THEN WE
MUST REMAIN OPPOSED FOR THE
REPORT STATED. THANK YOU. Q. X.
WITNESS COURSE ALL. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY CELLS
ARE LOW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WITH APPRECIATION
TO THE COMMITTEE AND AUTHOR FOR
CONTINUING WORK ON THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY WE AS WE WERE TO
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE MUST
OPPOSE SENATE BILL SIXTEEN
BILLION ACKERMAN OF SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE STATUTE AND
CASE LAW PROVIDED ENHANCED AN
APPROPRIATE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
FOR PEACE OFFICER PERSONAL
RECORDS. AS WELL AS METHODS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH
RECORDS COULD BE ACCESSED SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE MADE
SPECIFIED RECORDS AVAILABLE FOR
PUBLIC DISPLEASURE BUT MAINLY
LIMITED THE SCOPE OF WHAT COULD
BE RELEASED RECORDS RELATING TO
USES OF FORCE THAT RESULTED IN
DEATH OR GREAT BODILY INJURY OR
OTHER SITUATIONS IN WHICH A
COMPLAINT OF WRONGDOING HAD
BEEN SUSTAINED. AS MR FELDMAN
NOTED SB SIXTEEN ELIMINATES THE
REQUIREMENT THE RECORDS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR RELEASE REGARDING
USES OF FORCE BE LIMITED TO
THOSE SITUATIONS INVOLVING
DEATH OR GREAT BODILY INJURY
AND INSTEAD MAKES NEARLY ALL
RECORDS RELATIVE TO NEARLY ANY
USE OF FORCE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC THIS IS AN EXCEEDINGLY
BROAD EXPANSION OF EXISTING LAW.
FURTHER THE BILL LANGUAGE
PROVIDING THAT THE ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE. CANNOT BE
ASSERTED TO LIMIT THE
DISCLOSURE OF FACTUAL
INFORMATION IS UNNECESSARY. AND
COULD UNDERMINE EFFECTIVE
REPRESENTATION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BY THEIR COUNSEL.
UNDER EXISTING CASE LAW AND
GENERALLY SPEAKING INFORMATION
THAT IS NOT OTHERWISE
PRIVILEGED DOES NOT BECOME
PRIVILEGED SIMPLY BECAUSE IS
COMMUNICATED TO AN ATTORNEY.
ADDITIONALLY PERMITTING
DISCLOSURE OF BILLING RECORDS.
AS LITIGATION UNFOLDS COULD
ALLOW PLAINTIFFS TO DETERMINE
WHERE THE ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING THE MUNICIPALITY
IS FOCUSING. HIS OR HER EFFORTS
ON DEFENSE INCLUDING WHAT
SERIES OUR DEFENSES THEY INTEND
TO PURSUE. ADDITIONALLY AS MR
FROM ANOTHER WE STRONGLY OBJECT
TO THE PROVISIONS ESTABLISH
CIVIL FINES IN THE ABILITY SEE
COSTS AND ATTORNEYS FEES IF AN
AGENCY FAILED TO DISCLOSE.
TIMELY DISCLOSE FOR PROPERLY
REDACT SPECIFIED RECORDS IT
OFTEN TAKES CONSIDERABLE TIME
TO PURPOSELY REDACTED PREPARE
RECORDS RELEASED AND THIS
REALITY WILL BE EXACERBATED BY
THE INCREASED NUMBER OF RECORDS
THAT ARE MADE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC BY THIS BILL. EVEN A
HARMLESS MISTAKE OR AN
INADVERTENT DELAY IN RELEASE
COULD SUBJECT ALREADY CASH
STRAPPED LOCAL AGENCIES TO
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL HARM. FOR
THOSE REASONS AND AGAIN WITH
RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR- WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW
MOVING TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANNA FORTY TWO OH
THREE HERE. THE RUMOR IN THE
GALLERY ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. SHE NINE WERE
MOVING OUT TO HER. NINE TWENTY
FORTY. ARE TERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION- S. B. SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY FORTY CHAIN HEARING
ON WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINE. MODERATORS DO WE
HAVE CALLERS IN Q. AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH ONLINE NUMBER
AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE. BUTTON ZERO NOW. AND
AT THE TIME OF THE GERMAN WE
HAVE FOUR PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU. WE WILL CALL AND
WERE MOBILISED IS THEIR QUEUE
WILL TAKE OFF. THANK YOU ONE
NUMBER THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DEAR ALEUTIAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION LOS ANGELES POLICE
CRITICALLY. AND THE DEPUTY
SHERIFFS OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY-
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL ONE APOLOGIZED TO THE
OFFICER. FOR THE HARDINESS OF
US. BEING ABLE TO GET TO OUR
OFFICE WELL AS WE HAD A LATE
BILL REVIEW PROCESS- BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO. HOPEFULLY
WORKING WELL ALONGSIDE OR THE
X. OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BY NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MATT USUALLY
WITH A CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
PREDOMINANTLY AROUND THE LACK
OF REQUIREMENT FOR SUSTAIN
FINDING BROWN REASONABLE OR
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE. BUT
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU OUT THERE AND
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO REMEDY OUR
ISSUES THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BY NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SHARON UNDER THAT
LEAVES OUR CITY A CUDDLE WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
WE ALSO MUST EXPECTING OPPOSE
SENATE BILL SIXTEEN MEASURE IS
EXPECTED IN THE TYPES OF
PERSONNEL RECORDS THAT MAKES
SUBJECT TO DISCLOSURE. OVERLY
PUNITIVE IN EVERY DOES YOUR
NAME AND- YOUR NAME. IN YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BLY NUMBER FORTY ONE IS. PLEASE
GO. GOOD AFTERNOON- A MOMENT-
JOHN LEVEL CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC OFFICE. IT WE ARE
WILL- BOB. WELL COM OF
MISSPELLED BY ITSELF YOU KNOW
WE THE QUICK BOB THIS BY THE
MOST ON. THAT WE DO THE OF FOR
THEIR AND OPPOSITE TO YOUR OR
INTERNET THANK YOU. AT THE TIME
OF THE TERM AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU OKAY NO FURTHER
WITNESSES IN Q. BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY THE
COMMITTEE. MANBIJ SURE. FURTHER
SKINNER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRING THIS BILL TO THE
FOREFRONT I AM VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT IN
IN PLACE SPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR- PUBLIC AGENCIES.
IN THAT RESPECT- I DO HAVE MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE AND
FRIENDS WHO ARE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SO MY VIEW AB
ON THAT END IS COMES FROM A-
CONCERNED THAT I HAVE WITH
REGARDS TO. HAVE ACCESS TO
PUBLIC RECORDS SPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF WATER THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE'RE IN. I CANNOT IMAGINE
LOSING A FAMILY MEMBER. TO TO
AN INCIDENT WHERE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS INVOLVED AND-
YOU KNOW WE- ARE NOW SAID
BUCKLEY HEREBY WE PRAY FOR A
LOT ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
SPECIALLY- THOSE WHO ARE AT THE
FRONT AT THE FRONT LINES OF. OF
SITUATIONS WHERE IT MAKES IT
VERY DIFFICULT TO THINK WITH
THE FRONTAL LOBE OF HER BRAIN
IN PURSES THE REACTIVE FROM A
PART OF THE ROOM OUR BRAIN SO.
THAT'S THE- THE CONTEXT IN
WHICH I A I'M I'M SPEAKING IN
ASKING QUESTIONS BECAUSE- THERE
ARE MANY ASPECTS THAT I
RESPECTED AND APPRECIATED THE
SPELL BUT THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS THAT I DO HAVE. I'M
ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE
IS GOING FURTHER THAN FIVE
YEARS- THE IN INFORMATION IS
THERE A REASON FOR THAT THAT
FIVE YEAR TIME FRAME THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO GOING
FURTHER BACK IN NOT HAVING A
LIMITED TIME FRAME. AND COMING
FROM A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE FROM
THE SCHOOL BOARD WHERE- YOU
KNOW I UNDERSTAND WE IN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS SMALL WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF STAFF IN
OUR AND- WHEN THE REQUEST
PUBLIC RECORDS IT REALLY DOES
TAKE A LOT OF TIME- FROM. THE
LIMITED STOCK THAT WE DO HAVE
SO THAT IS A CONCERN FOR ME- AS
FAR AS BE ABLE TO. BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT- THAT INFORMATION
AND IN A TIMELY AND- IN A
TIMELY WAY. ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE- UNLIMITED- TIME FRAMES
FOR REQUESTING RECORDS. A
PERMISSION TO ANSWER ANY
PROTECTIONS PERMISSION THANK
YOU- SOME OF THE DAY'S A GOOD
QUESTION AND THE HISTORY OF WHY
A FIVE YEAR RETENTION OF
RECORDS WAS- PUT INTO PLACE IS
PRIOR TO ABOUT FORTY FOUR YEARS
AGO NOW. ALL POLICE RECORDS
WERE AVAILABLE UNDER THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT ANY AND ALL. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WAS FOUND
WAS THAT AGENCIES WERE
DESTROYING THE RECORDS SO THEY
DID NOT HAVE TO RELEASE THEM
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A THAT ENOUGH
TO RELEASE IT. AND THERE WAS NO%
REAL ISSUE THE PROHIBITION ON
THEY'RE DESTROYING THEM. SO THE
GOVERNOR BROWN IN HIS FIRST
TERM SO PRIOR TO HIS MOST
RECENT SERVICES GOVERNOR. ENDED
UP. NEGOTIATING A BILL THAT
WOULD BASICALLY. GIVE HER A NEW
NóI OR WORD STOP ALL PUBLIC
CCESS BUT REQUIRE AGENCIES TO
AT LEAST HOLD ON TO RECORDS FOR
FIVE YEARS TO STOP THE
DESTRUCTION OF RECORDS. NOW
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT OTHER
PUBLIC THAT THE PUBLIC RECORDS
LINE ITSELF IF YOUR EVEN YOUR
SCHOOL THE DID THE ISSUE OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE ROLE OF THEY CAN ONLY KEEP
RECORDS FOR FIVE YEARS THEY
HAVE THE ROLE THAT YOU HAVE TO
KEEP RECORDS. THERE ISN'T A
PARTICULAR TIME PERIOD. AND
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT ALL USED
THE EXAMPLE OF THE DIRECTOR OF
IN CASE AND- WHERE HE IS NOW-
BEFORE THE COURT FOR THE-
MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD AND-
IT'S A REAL NUMBER ONE WE WOULD
HAVE NEVER KNOWN. IN CALIFORNIA
PRIOR TO FOURTEEN TWENTY WELL
EVEN UNDER FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
WE WOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN THAT HE
HAD A HISTORY OF FOR EXAMPLE
USE OF FORCE AND ALSO
DISCRIMINATORY OR BIASED
BEHAVIOR WE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO GET THAT. NOW IT'S ALSO
WOULD WOULD APPEAR FROM THE
REPORTS IS THAT. WITH THAT
INDIVIDUAL IT GOES BACK. MANY
MANY MANY YEARS. AND HAD WE AND
IF THIS WERE CALIFORNIA AND WE
WOULD HAVE PERHAPS IF HE HAD
NOT. ACTED IN SUCH A WAY AND
MAYBE THERE WAS ONLY ONE
INCIDENT OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD WE WOULD THINK OKAY THIS
IS AN OFFICER ONLY HAD ONE
INCIDENT WHERE IS MAYBE OVER
TEN YEAR PERIOD HE HAD TWENTY.
SO THE FIVE YEAR RETENTION THAT
WAS IN THE ORIGINAL LAW. WAS
REAL PRETTY ARBITRARY I DIDN'T
REALLY GIVE US A FULL. PICTURE
OF. A CIRCUMSTANCE AN OFFICER
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT MANY
TIMES AFTER THERE IS A USE OF
FORCE AND OFFICERS PUT ON
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE UNTIL
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETED AND
WE'VE TAKEN THREE FOUR YEARS
BEFORE WE COMPLETE
INVESTIGATIONS SO IN THAT THREE
OR FOUR YEARS THAT THEY MAY BE
ON ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE. OF
COURSE THEY'RE NOT ENGAGING IN
OTHER BEHAVIORS BUT MAYBE THEY
DID WELL PRIOR TO THAT. AND SO
AGAIN I'M TRYING TO PUT HAT
TIME PERIOD- NOW THE VAST
MAJORITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN THE STATE. DO NOT
DRAW THEIR WEAPONS DO NOT
ENGAGE IN REASONABLE FORCE AND
DO NOT ENGAGE IN THE MISCONDUCT
THAT THESE THAT ARE MY BILLS
EITHER FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE OR
THIS ONE WOULD AFFECT- SO WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT
UNFORTUNATELY A SMALL PERCENT.
BUT IT THAT IS WHY WE NEED THIS
INFORMATION SO BADLY BECAUSE WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HOLD
AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE. AND WHILE
JONATHON FELDMAN FROM THE
POLICE CHIEFS DIDN'T INDICATE
WHY THE POLICE CHIEFS SUPPORTED
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE PART OF IT
WAS EVEN THE CHEEKS COULD NOT.
ACCESS INFORMATION ABOUT
OFFICERS THEY WERE HIRING FROM
ANOTHER. JURISDICTION SO THEY
DIDN'T KNOW WERE THAT WERE THEY
GETTING AN OFFICER WITH A
HISTORY OF. EITHER BIASED
BEHAVIOR OR UNLAWFUL SEARCHES
OR YOU KNOW USE OF FORCE THEY
DIDN'T KNOW SO NOW THEY CAN NO.
AND AS YOU HEARD THE PRINCIPAL
CONCERN THE CHIEFS HAVE IS THE-
IN FACT I AM NOT TO MINIMIZE IT
BUT THE SORT OF PAPERWORK
BURDEN. BUT IF WE LOOK AT.
THERE WILL BE ABSOLUTELY THERE
WILL BE A GREAT INCREASE IN
REQUEST AS SOON AS THE BILL IS
IN EFFECT BUT THEN AFTER THAT
SO THEN PASSED THINGS WILL HAVE
TO BE DISCLOSED YES THAT PUTS A
BURDEN ON THE AGENCY. BUT ONCE
THOSE ARE DISCLOSED IT IS ONLY
ANY ANY ACTION MOVING FORWARD.
AND WHAT WE WOULD CERTAINLY
HOPE IS THAT VERY FEW OF THESE
ACTIONS WOULD OCCUR AND THAT
OUR AGE AND SO THEN THIS IS NOT
A BURDEN. SO I JUST WANTED TO
BRING THAT UP. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU HE DISCOVERS WHAT. SUCH AS
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS GOOD
POINT AND I THINK YU MENTIONED
ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT I
ACTUALLY. QUITE ADMIRED ABOUT
THE BILL IS THE FACT THAT YOU
KNOW WHEN. POLICE OFFICERS ARE
BEING HIGHER CONSIDER FURTHER
CONSIDERATION OR FOR OTHER
POSITIONS IN OTHER AREAS THEY
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO LOOK. INTO
THE PAST HERE I THINK- THAT IS
ACTUALLY VERY- FAVORABLE. FOR
THE POLICE STATIONS THAT ARE
THE POLICE DISTRICT ARE
ACTUALLY HIRING THEM SO THAT
WAS A GOOD POINT AND IKE I
SAID. I THINK THERE ARE MANY
MANY GOOD POINTS. THAT ON THERE
I WAS JUST I AM VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LIMITATIONS- OR THE
PARAMETERS THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY- VERY DEFINED PARAMETERS
AND IT MAKES IT VERY. ON AT.
JUST OPEN ENDED BASICALLY SO
THAT'S AND THAT'S MY MAJOR
CONCERN AS FAR AS A TOOL FOR
MANY. AREAS HOPEFULLY THAT THEY
WILL BE HOPING YOU DON'T HAVE
THE CASE TO HAVE TO BE IN THE
AND THAT. BUT MOVING FORWARD
STILL I WOULD LOVE TO SEE. MORE
OF A- MORE DEFINED PARAMETERS.
AND ALSO A CONSIDERATION AS
WELL. IN THE- BEHAVIOR
ESPECIALLY WITH WITH- INCIDENTS
THAT HAPPENED YOU KNOW FURTHER
THAN- FURTHER BACK THAN FIVE
YEARS. IS THAT WHEN I LOOK. AT
TRAINING AND I LOOK AT
EXPERIENCE ESPECIALLY WHEN
WHERE MUCH OF THE TIME YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE REALLY ADAM YOU
KNOW YOU YOUR UNCERTAIN PART OF
YOUR BRAIN YEAR EUROPE
REACTION. REACTIONARY MODE AND
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO LEARN I
MEAN I'M TALKING AS A- FRESHMAN
SENATOR HERE WHO. GETS IN FRONT
OF A MICROPHONE IN FRONT OF IT
PEOPLE AND I GET SO NERVOUS I
HAVE A HARD TIME THINKING SITES
CAN ONLY IMAGINE WENT OFFICERS
IS. IN A SITUATION THAT IS. YOU
KNOW NOT AT. OPTIMAL- AT.
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT I ALSO THAT
WITH EXPERIENCE COMES THE
ABILITY TO MAKE BETTER
JUDGMENTS AND BETTER. DECISIONS
WHEN. PERFORMING ONCE DUTIES.
AND SOME A LITTLE CONCERNED
THAT- WITH THE OPENING OF THE
ACTS OF BEING FOR THAN FIVE
YEARS THAT. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE TO IN
EXPERIENCE. AND AND- THE LACK
OF BEING ON THE FRONTLINE OF
THE PROFESSION. AND SO I A ALSO
BELIEVE IN IN GIVING GRAYSON
I'M WHICH IS WHY I BELIEVE IN
IN IN PRISON REFORM AS WELL. IN
LOOKING AT THAT BUT WITH
BALANCING PROTECTIONS AND SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE- IF I WERE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS THIS BILL IN
SUPPORT. IS TO SEE PARAMETERS
AND EVELYN HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
GRACE FOR EXPERIENCE FOR
OFFICERS THAT PERHAPS MADE.
MIGHT HAVE DONE A COUPLE OF.
MISTAKES IN IN THEIR- IN THE
ERROR. IN THEIR JOB- PER SE. IN
DOING THEIR JOB DUE TO LACK OF
EXPERIENCE AND HOLDING THAT
AGAINST THEM IN A WAY BECAUSE-
IT'S NOT EASY I CAN'T IMAGINE I
MEAN IT I COULD NOT I DON'T
HAVE THE COURAGE TO BE IN THE
FRONT LINES. IN THE MILITARY
AND I DON'T HAVE IT TO BE A
PEACE OFFICER SO I DO HAVE. A
LITTLE BIT OF COMPASSION AND
UNDERSTANDING ON THAT AND DID
NOT THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT I
DON'T. BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
ACCOUNTABLE THEY ARE HERE TO
PROTECT US AND DO WELL BUT- FOR
THOSE WHO. HAVE THE EXPERIENCE
OF BEING IN THE FRONT LINES AND
DO THAT UNFORTUNATELY I DO I DO
HAVE A LIMIT OF CONCERN ON THAT
END. FINNISH COMMITTEE WANNA
DRESS CENTER- IT IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING WE WILL CONTINUE TO
TALK WITH THE OPPOSITION ABOUT
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD AND-
IT. IT'S ABSOLUTELY THE CASE
THAT WITH EXPERIENCE- ONE'S
ABILITY TO NOTE TO LEARN BETTER
HOW HOW DO DE CONTEXTS AND
SITUATIONS TO REACT. ON. BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE
OPPOSITION ABSOLUTELY AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AND TRYING TO
MAKE A- A BILL THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE IN IN A MANNER THAT IS
EQUITABLE AND FAIR- AND WITH
GRACE FOR EVERYONE FOR NOT JUST
THE AND IN. ESSENCE TO HONOR
THE FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES. WHICH CAN'T IMAGINE
BUT ALSO PROTECT THOSE WHO ARE.
FOR TAKING THE INITIATIVE TO
PROTECT US AS WELL SO- YOU KNOW
THAT MY HEART IS INTHE RIGHT
PLACE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING AND HELPING DEVICE AT A
GOOD- WELL ROUNDED POLICY FOR
ALL OF THE SAFETY FOR THE WELL
BEING OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SHE NINE
ARTIFICERS CAN ARM AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS MEASURE I THINK
IT'S A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
THAT'S LONG OVERDUE I THINK
HISTORY HAS SHOWN US THAT THE
LONGER THE OFFICER WHO HAS
COMMITTED A ACTS SUCH AS THIS
CASE CONTINUES THROUGHOUT THE
CAREER IT'S NOT A ONE AND DONE
IT'S NOT A LACK OF EXPERIENCE
IT'S A MINDSET. AND I FIND IT
VERY INTERESTING THAT MR
FELDMAN STATED THAT THEY ARE
FOR TRANSPARENCY I WOULD IF YOU
STILL ON THE LINE I WOULD LIKE
HIM TO ADDRESS PARTY HOW DOES
HE RESPOND TO THE NUMBER OF
AGENCIES THAT DESTROYED RECORDS
JUST WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS BEFORE
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
A FACT TWO YEARS AGO ONE BEING
IN MY OWN DISTRICT SHOW I
WOULD. LOVE TO HEAR THE
JUSTIFICATION ON WHY- WE SHOULD
BELIEVE THAT. POLICE CHIEF OR
THEIR AGENCY SUPPORT
TRANSPARENCY THEY'RE DESTROYING
RECORDS BEFORE THE BILL WENT
INTO EFFECT. YEAH HI SENATOR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION. AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN AND I'M NOT GOING TO
THE SPEAKER THOSE AGENCIES TO
TRY AND JUSTIFY THEIR ACTIONS I
MEAN THAT WAS THEIR DECISION-
IT'S NOT REPRESENTATIVE I THINK
OF THE BOOK OF THE POLICE
CHIEFS OR OF THE ASSOCIATION.
IS LEADERSHIP CLEARLY STOOD
WITH- SKINNER ON HER PRIOR BILL
LOBBIED FOR IT BUT I WAS THE
ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUP TO
STAND OUT AGAINST THAT MAN.
WHICH TO DO- TAKE ACTION BUT
THE IT IS YOU KNOW BASED OFF A
YOU KNOW WHAT FACT THEY LOOK
OUT AT THE LOW LEVEL- YEAH. YES
AS USUAL SPEAK INTO THE AGENT.
WE CAN JUST SAY THAT ARE
LEADERSHIP OUR- ARE YOU. TEAM
YOU KNOW AS A AS A WRECK FOR
WORK WITH FOLKS BILLS LIKE THIS
OF STANDING WITH FOLKS.
INCREASED I'M NOT SURE HOPE. TO
DO AGAIN I HOPE WE CAN THROUGH-
SOME THE CONCERNS ABOUT EARLIER.
TO THANK YOU BUT I THINK IT'S
TO. THE L. WE'RE TO ADDRESS THE
ONE OFFS BACK STAYING THE
WHOLE. INDUSTRY AND I THINK THE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU JUST GAVE THAT
YOUR SITUATION TRONG SUPPORTS
TRANSPARENCY BUT YOU HAVE
AGENCIES WITHIN YOUR
ORGANIZATION THAT'S THE SAME AS
UP. A ROBOCOP THAT CHANGE OLD
APARTMENT EVEN THOUGH THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN. DO THEIR JOB IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY. AND I WOULD
JUST ADDRESS TO THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW. HOW ONE'S. BRAIN
FUNCTIONS IT SEEMS LIKE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BRING FUNCTIONS
QUITE WELL WHEN THEY ENCOUNTER
WHITE MEN WHO ARE ARMED
SOMETIMES AND DANGERS BUT-
THEIR BRAIN SEEMS TO WORK A LOT
DIFFERENT WHEN IT'S BLACK AND
BROWN SHOW UP. AGAIN I THINK
YOU FOR THIS MEASURE WE ALSO
WOULD STILL THAT'S WE HAD SOME-
CALLERS ON. OFF IN OPPOSITION
THAT. WE DO GET TO. IT TO SO
MAN MODERATOR CAN YOU CHECK THE
LINE ONCE AGAIN TO SEE IF THERE
ANY CALLS IN QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIXTEEN PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTEEN. ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR. AT THIS
TIME NO ONE IS SHOWING UP THERE.
YOUR WE'VE GIVEN YOUR CHANCE
OVER CHECK THE LINES OKAY
HEARING NO OTHER OPPOSITION HER
NO OTHER DISCUSSION BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SANDERS CAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- IN MEMBERS
THE- WHAT I FOUND PARTICULARLY
STRIKING WAS- CEPHUS JOHNSON
UNCLE BOBBIE'S COMMENTED ABOUT
EVEN IN THE TIME SINCE OSCAR
GRANT'S MURDER IN THAT
PARTICULAR OFFICER WAS
PROSECUTED AND CONVICTED. THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN OVER A
THOUSAND- DEATHS AT THE HANDS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS IN
CALIFORNIA- AND WHAT I THINK HE
REFERENCED A MAYBE THERE WERE
OTHER PEOPLE THAT WE NEED A
CULTURE CHANGE AND IN A WAY
TRANSPARENCY WILL HELP US
ACHIEVE A CULTURE CHANGE AND
WHEN I SAY THAT I ALSO SEE THAT
AS IN THE INDICATED EARLIER THE
VAST VAST MAJORITY OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS ARE NOT.
IN THAT MODE THEY ARE NOT AND
EVERYONE OF THEM REGARDLESS OF
THEIR PARTICULAR ATTITUDES TAKE
THEIR LIVES IN THEIR HANDS
EVERY TIME THEY PUT ON THAT
UNIFORM AND WALK OUT THEIR DOOR
AND WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE PUT
AT RISK VERY OFTEN BUT AND
SADLY IF WE REFER TO THE BILL
WE HEARD JUST EARLIER VERY
OFTEN IN DOMESTIC CALLS THAT
THAT CAN BE THE MOST RISKY AND
YET THEY RESPOND AND THEY SHOW
UP. AND SO WE WANT TO ACHIEVE
MY OBJECTIVE IS TO ACHIEVE
SAFETY FOR EVERYONE SAFETY FOR
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
SAFETY FOR OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND TO HAVE OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT HELL TO WHAT IS
APPROPRIATELY A VERY HIGH
STANDARD AND I THINK THIS TYPE
OF TRANSPARENCY WILL HELP US DO
IT AND I CERTAINLY COMMIT TO
CONTINUING TO TALK TO THE
OPPOSITION TO. SEE WHETHER
THERE ARE MODIFICATIONS THAT
CAN SWITCH THEIR CONCERNS AND
YET STILL ACHIEVE THE OBJECTIVE
OF THE BILL AND FINALLY I WOULD
SAY THAT IF WE LOOK AT OTHER
STATES WHILE THIS BILL DOES
EXPAND THE ACCESS TO RECORDS WE
ARE STILL NOT GIVING FULL
ACCESS TO EVERY TYPE OF POLICE
MISCONDUCT AND IF WE COMPARE
FOR EXAMPLE NEW YORK STATE OHIO
MANY MANY OTHER STATES KENTUCKY
EVEN THEY HAVE FULL 1100%
ACCESS THERE'S NO LIMITATION ON
THE RECORDS THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN- OBTAIN. SO IT IS STILL ON
I HAVE A NOTE THIS MAY NOT BE
OF PRECEDED BY SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION BUT IT IS STILL
MODEST COMPARED TO OTHER STATES
AND WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A TO PASS TO
JUDICIAL RECOMMENDATION CAN WE
GET A MOTION ON. THIS MEASURE.
ANY MEMBER WILLING TO MAKE A
MOTION ON SB. SIXTEEN ANY
MEMBER WANTED TO MAKE A MOTION
ON S. B. SIXTEEN. CENTER WINTER
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A DO
PASSED YOU JUDICIARY. ADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SB SIXTEEN TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
BRADFORD AREN'T FOR DIETRO AGO.
ADOBO GUYS BY IN OUR AYE WIENER
WIENER I'D FOUR ZERO. THAT
MEASURES OUT FOUR ZERO THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER NEXT UP IS
SENATOR WIENER WE HAVE. S. P.
SEVENTY THREE- WHEN YOU'RE
PREPARED SB SEVENTY THREE I
THANK YOU- MISTER THANK YOU
DEARLY COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US IN THIS BILL COLLEAGUES
ARE SENATE BILL SEVENTY THREE
WILL REPEAL MANDATORY MINIMUM.
PRISON OR JAIL SENTENCES FOR
PEOPLE CONVICTED OF CERTAIN
NONVIOLENT DRUG OFFENSES AND
WILL PROVIDE JUDGES- WITH THE
DISCRETION TO GRANT PROBATION
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS TO BE
CLEAR- THIS LEGISLATION DOES
NOT REDUCE THE MAXIMUM PENALTY
NOR DOES IT ELIMINATE THE
POSSIBILITY OF JAIL- INSTEAD-
IT GIVES JUDGES DISCRETION
BASED ON THE CASE TO DECIDE
WHETHER A JAIL OR PRISON
SENTENCE MAKE SENSE OR WHETHER
PROVISION MAKES SENSE CURRENTLY
FOR A LAUNDRY LIST. OF
NONVIOLENT DRUG OFFENSES IN
CALIFORNIA. FIVE A JUDGE IS
MANDATED TO SEND THE PERSON TO
JAIL OR PRISON I HAS NO
DISCRETION NO MATTER WHAT THE
FACTS OF THE CASE. TO PUT THE
PERSON ON PROBATION INSTEAD-
THIS MAKES NO SENSE- THIS FUELS
MASS INCARCERATION WE KNOW THAT
THE WAR ON DRUGS- MANDATING
THAT WE PUT PEOPLE IN PRISON
FOR NONVIOLENT DRUG OFFENSES.
HAS BEEN ABJECT FAILURE IT
HASN'T REDUCED DRUG USE THAT
HAS A REDUCED- ADDICTION ALL
IT'S DONE IS FUELED
INCARCERATION CROWDED OUR
JAILS. ARE TAKING MONEY AWAY
FROM HEALTH AND EDUCATION OTHER
CRITICAL NEEDS AND FRANKLY IT'S
SHOCKING THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
MANDATE THAT NONVIOLENT DRUG
OFFENDERS GO TO PRISON EVEN IF
THE JUDGE THING SEPARATION. IS
MORE APPROACH- THE SYSTEM HAS
FAILED IT'S TIME TO GIVE JUDGES
DISCRETION TO MAKE THAT CHOICE
INSTEAD OF MANDATING OUT- AND
SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON S.
B. SEVENTY THREE. WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION OUR JUDGE HARLING
GROSSMAN WHO IS A RETIRED
JUDGE- WITH THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT- AND THE
NEXT TO IT- AND WHO IS AN
APPELLATE ATTORNEY. AT THE LOS
ANGELES PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU. IT'S JUDGE GROSSMAN
PREPARE TO FORGE TESTIMONY. YES
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
MARLA GROSSMAN I'M A RETIRED
JUDGE FROM CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
I RETIRED NINE YEARS AGO AFTER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF JUDICIAL
SERVICE I WAS A PROSECUTOR FOR
NINE YEARS BEFORE BECOMING A
JUDGE. SINCE RETIRING I'VE BEEN
ACTIVE IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
POLICY ADVOCATES IN. I'M HERE
THIS MORNING TO ADVOCATE IN
FAVOR OF SENATE BILL SEVENTY
THREE WHICH WOULD REPEAL THE
PROBATION OF ABILITY AND
ARTISTIC PENSION OF SENSES
PROVISIONS FOR CERTAIN
ENUMERATED NONVIOLENT DRUG
OFFENSES. THERE BY RESTORING
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO IMPOSE
APPROPRIATE SENTENCES TAILORED
TO THE INDIVIDUAL CIRCUMSTANCES
OF EACH DEFENDANT THAT COMES
BEFORE THE COURT. RESTRICTIONS
ON JUDICIAL DISCRETION IN
SENTENCING DO NOT SERVE AS A
DETERRENT TO CRIME. RATHER THEY
ONLY SERVE TO LIMIT THE
DISCRETION IN THE HANDS OF
JUDGES TIED THE HANDS OF JUDGES
INVOLVED IN THE EDUCATION THIS
POSITION AND RESOLUTION OF
THESE CASES. IT MAKES LITTLE
SENSE TO LIMIT JUDICIAL
DISCRETION ON THE THING OF
THESE MATTERS. JUDGES RETAIN AN
EXERCISE THEIR DISCRETION ON
MUCH WEIGHTIER ISSUES SUCH AS
WHETHER TO IMPOSE THE DEATH
PENALTY. WHETHER TO STRIKE THE
STRIKE CONVICTION WHETHER A
CASE SHOULD PROCEED IN JUVENILE
COURT OR BE TRANSFERRED TO
CRIMINAL FOR ADULT COURT. WHEN
IT COMES TO SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT HAVE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH. THE
CHORE MINIMUM SENSORS ARE NOT
AFFECTED IN ANY WAY INCLUDING
NOT BEING COST EFFECTIVE.
CONNECTING SENATE BILL SEVENTY
THREE WILL PERMIT MORE
EFFECTIVE THE SENATE BASED
SENTENCING AND MORE EFFICIENT
USE CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL
JUSTICE RESOURCES- JANET HI
VOTE ON SENATE BILL SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING TO
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS NICK JORDAN I'M A PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. SB SEVENTY THREE
IT DESIGNED TO ADDRESS DAMAGING
ANTIQUATED HOLD OVER THE WAR ON
DRUGS THE STATURE TO PREVENT
CALIFORNIANS CONVICTED OF THE
SECOND DRUG OFFENSE NO MATTER
HOW MINOR BEING PLACED ON
PROBATION. I SPOKEN TO THIS
COMMITTEE PREVIOUSLY ABOUT
PUTTING A HUMAN FACE ON THE
DAMAGE CAUSED BY THIS TERRIBLE
PUBLIC POLICY MY OPERA CLIENT
ALLEN TWELVE WHEN SHE WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED TO TREAT DRUGS IN
HER CASE IT WAS HER MOTHER A
PARTIALLY PARALYZED CHAIRMAN
ADDICTS WHO TOLD ALEX TO HELP
REJECT. YOUR DAILY DOSE IRWIN.
BECAUSE ALL OF HER MOTHER OTHER
DAY TAKEAWAY. A TWELVE YEAR OLD
LITTLE GIRL WAS FORCED INJECT
HEROIN INTO A MOTHERS GROW. SIX
YEARS LATER I ENTIRE ON. OUR
PICKED UP HER FIRST AND EIGHT
YEARS AFTER THAT GOING APPEARED
BRIDEI SHOULD PICK UP HER
SECOND. BECAUSE A BIT STATUTE
OUT DEEMED INELIGIBLE FOR
PROBATION RECEIVED A THREE YEAR
COUNTY JAIL. THAT THANK BEING
LIKE OUT OF PRISON ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY'RE PROVEN
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE CHEAPER
AND MORE LIKELY TO ADDRESS
ADDICTION REPEATED THE NEED. IS
NEEDLESSLY CRUEL AND IT'S
SIMPLY BAD PUBLIC POLICY. I
WANT TO LEAVE THE COMMITTEE
MAYBE WITH IT BY AND IT OUT
ATTACK THEM BE QUITE AT
BRANDISHED A GUN OR A KNIFE
TWICE. OR LEGALLY SOLD SOMEBODY
AUTOMATIC WEAPON TWICE SHE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ELIGIBLE FOR
PROBATION. HOWEVER BECAUSE OF
THIS STATUTE AND IT'S VERY
STRANGE CONCLUSION OF THE WAY
TO DEAL WITH TRAUMATIZED ILL
CALIFORNIANS THAT THE PRESIDENT
PRISON. SHE WAS NOT IS THE VIEW
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN TIME
FOR THAT TO CHANGE. GALLAGHER
DR VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO THROUGH
FORTY TWO ALL THREE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE. KERN
SCENE NINE WE'RE MOVING TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM ERRORS OR ANY
WITNESSES AND WITH. MMHM-
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY THIRTY
START. TWENTY FORTY I'M SORRY
ANYONE WITH THIS IS IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY. SCENE NINE NOW
WILL MOVE TO OUR PHONE LINES
MODERATOR ARE THERE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT VETERAN CUTE TO
TESTIFY ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. SEVENTY THREE
POINT PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO.
RATABLE PROVIDE YOU WITH MY
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. THE MESSAGE I'M AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NINE PEOPLE
IN Q. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR. WILL TAKE THE FIRST
CALL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU LOOK
FOR THIS. LINE NUMBER FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER COMMITTEE GOING BACK AS
FOR DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
SPONSORS OF SB SEVENTY THREE IN
SUPPORT AND WITHOUT THE NAME OF
THE ORGANIZATION HELLO BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. LIE NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEMENTARA BEHALF OF
THE PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MARK JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS. WHY
NUMBER FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THIS. FINAL THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANAHER DONNA ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER
THANK YOU STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR THIS. LINE NUMBER FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS DANIEL LANDS MEN WITH
FAMILIES AGAINST MANDATORY
MINIMUMS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE OF
THE FORTY FOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD SH. THANK YOU MR SHARE
THIS IS NINETY HIGHER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY WORK ORGANIZATION
AGAIN- IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THE QUICKNESS. NUMBER
TWENTY ONE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DANIEL B.
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BY NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY NUMBER THIRTY FIVE A
LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN. HI MISTER CHAIR
GOOD MORNING WITH CENTRIST WITH
MILLER SAYS BUT AS AN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF RESTORE
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WILL HAVE NO ONE OF THE
Q. THANK YOU. LET'S NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE AND ROOM FORTY
TWO ALL THREE AND OPPOSITION.
TO THIS MEASURE SB SEVENTY
THREE. NINETEEN NINE WILL MOVE
TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM OF TWENTY
FORTY. THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVENTY THREE
AND ROOM TWENTY FORTY. HEARING
SEEN NINE. MODERATOR ARE THEIR
COLLARS IN Q. AND OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB SEVENTY THREE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER IN
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE. THERE ARE NOW.
SEVERAL PROMISES AND WE HAD TWO
PEOPLE IN Q. WE'LL TAKE THE
FIRST WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN LINE
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO GO
AHEAD. A GREG BIRD WOULD BE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THE
QUICKNESS. BY NUMBER TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. REMEMBERS RANDY PERRY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HIGH PATROL AND
PORK IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL CALLERS. AT THE
TIME AT THE TIME AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU BRING
ME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON SB
SEVENTY THREE. IN CHAIN NINE.
CENTER WHERE WE TALK TO CLOSE.
REQUEST FOR AN IRA. QS CENTER
WHEN YOU'RE SEEKING A FIVE VOTE
ON S. B. SEVENTY THREE. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION TO
PASSED TO- WHICH YOU CAN MOTION
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR SCANNER-
MADAM CELL TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. IT TOO FAST TO RATIONS
YES SB SEVENTY THREE DO PASSAGE
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD AREN'T
RIGHT FOR DIETRO BOGUE. NO VOTE
NOT THE JOB OF NOT VOTING
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE WIENER ALL
RIGHT WHEN ARE AYE VOTERS THREE
ZERO IMAGES OUT THREE ZERO.
THANK YOU SIR WIENER MATCH UP
IS SENATOR MCGUIRE'S S. B.
NINETY EIGHT WHICH I WILL BE
PRESENTING. ON HIS BEHALF I
WILL HAND TO GOBBLE OVER TERM
VOICED YOUR- SENATOR A CHEWABLE.
WELCOME SENATOR BRADFORD THANK
YOU. PLEASE PRESENT YOUR BILL
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CENTER IN REGARDS PRESENT S. B.
NINETY EIGHT WHICH IS THE
FREEDOM OF PRESS. FRIEDMAN
BREAST IS ONE OF THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL ALL RIGHT. ERICA
HOUSE IT WAS THE FOUNDING OF
OUR- COUNTRY FREEDOM OF PRESS
THAT SAID THERE ARE CRACKS. IN
THIS FREEDOM HERE IN AMERICA
AND SB NINETY EIGHT HELPS
STRENGTHEN THE PEOPLE'S RIGHT
TO KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THEIR COUNTRY ACCORDING TO THE
FREEDOM OF PRESS FOUNDATION AND
THE COMMITTEE TO PROTECT
JOURNALISTS. THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
INCIDENTS IN THE UNITED STATES
REPORTED AGGRESSION AGAINST THE
PRESS ATTEMPTING TO DO THEIR
JOB THE FIRST AMENDMENT OVER
THE LAST YEAR ALONE IN MAY WE
SAW THIS HAPPENING IN PROTESTS
AND MARCHES THROUGHOUT OUR OWN
STATE FOLLOWING THE KILLING OF
GEORGE FLOYD. MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS RESTORE PERSONAL HEALTH
AND SAFETY EACH TIME THEY
ATTEND PROTEST RALLIES TO GET
PUBLIC GET THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED AND
DESERVE CALIFORNIA'S LEAD AWAY
TO ENSURE THE RIGHT OF THE
PRESS AND THE FIRST AMENDMENTS
ARE PROTECTED AND HELD TO THE
HIGHEST STANDARD. CURRENTLY IN
STATE LAW REPORTER FOR GRANTED
FORTY TO ENTER AREAS CLOSED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT DURING NATURAL
DISASTERS IN ORDER TO GATHER
INFORMATION AND RELAY THAT TO
THE PUBLIC. THEY CAN ALSO GO
OUT DURING CURFEWS AT TIMES OF
NATURAL NATURAL DISASTERS.
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE WE DO NOT
ACCEPT BASS PRESLEY EXTENT TO
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
DEMONSTRATIONS SUCH AS MARCHES
RALLIES DEMONSTRATIONS. I AM
PROTEST. SB NINETY EIGHT
EXTENSIVE CRUCIAL PROTECTIONS
TO MEMBERS OF THE PRESS AS A
CANNER AND REPORT ON EVENTS
PROTECTED PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT ADDITIONALLY SB
NINETY EIGHT ALLOWS REPORTERS A
CHANCE TO CHALLENGE THEIR THE
TEAM AT OR LACK OF ACCESS BY
WORKING WITH. MANAGEMENT ON THE
SCENE. THIS LANGUAGE PROVIDES
THE NECESSARY SAFETY NET TO
PROTECT REPORTERS. WHO ARE NOT
GRANTED ACCESS. INTENTIONALLY
DETAINED OR MISTAKENLY DETAINED
SB NINETY EIGHT WILL HELP
ENSURE JOURNALISTS CAN PERFORM
THESE. CRITICAL ROLES WHILE
BEING PROTECTED FROM ANY
OFFICER INTENTIONALLY
ASSAULTING OBSTRUCTING OR
INTERFERING WITH THEIR DUTIES
WHILE THEY'RE GATHERING THE
NEWS THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
ACLU CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
NEWSPAPER. PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION ETHNIC MEDIA
SERVICES AND THE REPORTERS
COMMITTEE. HERE TODAY
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THIS
MEASURE IS BRITNEY FOR SCOTTY
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION KEVIN BAKER A
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR ACLU.
APPROPRIATE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. DUE TO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAKE
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR ALL OTHER WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. AT THIS TIME WOULD
LIKE TO ASK KEVIN BAKER. IF
HE'S AVAILABLE TO GIVE HIS
TESTIMONY. MORNING MR MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KEVIN BACON
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA- EDUCATIONALISTS
IN YOUR BRADFORD IT'S ALL
ALREADY ELOQUENTLY PRESENTED
BUILT OVER A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE TO PROTECT. REPORTER
WHO AREN'T REALLY ON THE FRONT
LINES ON PROVIDING INFORMATION
WAS SO NECESSARY FOR THE PUBLIC
DISCOURSE ON THIS MATURATION
RECALLED WAS BEFORE YOU. LAST
YEAR- AND COME. TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK GOVERNOR HAD
SOME LINGERING CONCERNS WHICH
THE AUTHOR HAS NOW ADDRESSED
AND WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BAKER. WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT MS
BRITNEY PERSON OR SOMEBODY. ARE
YOU READY MISPERCEPTION AND
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRITAIN'S
ARE STUDY. GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
THE- ENSURE STRONG. NINE
ECKARDT COMMON STANDARD
BRADFORD AND KEVIN BERGER. AND
FOR. THE BECAUSE CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS COUNTRY- A LOT OF REST
OF THE BOTH GENERAL WITHOUT
BULLETS HAPPENS. THAT THE TIME
THAT. ACCORDING TO. A PRESS
OVER HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE.
OKAY IN TWENTY YEAH BROWN.
TRANSIT AND- BOB. MEMBERS OF
THE PRESS. IT FELT LIKE. ABOUT
AND NOT SURE ABOUT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH THE MORE VERY
INFORMATION INFORMED THEIR ARE
PEOPLE ON LOCATION THEM FROM
PARDON. BOB WILL PROVIDE
BELIEVE PROTECT. PROVIDE FOR I
ADDITIONAL OPEN MEMBERS OF THE
SHE. BEAR THE PENSION AND ALLOW
THEM TO KEEP. HOWEVER THAT. BUT
SHE BARI HISTORY ON. AND
ACTIVISTS ROGER I'LL VOEPEL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS. NOW
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE WITNESSES
HERE IN THE ROOM FOR SUPPORT.
OUR ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WISH TO TELL SO OF
S. B. NINETY EIGHT. SEEN ON. TO
HAVE ONE MORE ROOM. IN SUPPORT
DO WE HAVE ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ZERO
NINE. DO WE HAVE- ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NO ONE THERE WHEN WE
HAVE FORTY TWO OR THREE. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
EIGHT WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY EIGHT
PRESS ONE ZERO AND THE OPERATOR
WILL. TAKE CARE FILE OUT
COMPLETE AND GIVE YOUR LINE
ABOUT A PLACE YOU BACK IF YOU
WANT TO GIVE IT MORE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY EIGHT-
PRESS ONE. ZERO NOW. THANK YOU
MODERATE MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
YES MADAM HERE WE HAVE THREE
PEOPLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINETY EIGHT. I ONE MORE
TIME. WE HAVE THREE PEOPLE
THANK YOU. WELCOME MADAM CHAIR
AND MY NUMBERS NINE NUMBER TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LIE NUMBER FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS- TRACING. ROSENBERG
CALLING ON BEHALF OF YEAH
ALLIANCE AND OAKLAND PRIVACY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MY NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MARK POWERS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE RADIO AND TV
STATIONS SERVING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MODERATELY PLEASE CHECK THE
LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALSO SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON SB NINETY EIGHT.
YES MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. ONE ZERO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
EIGHT. MODERATE DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL MADAM CHAIR NO ONE
IS QUEUING UP. THANK YOU
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE-
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY.
YEAH ARE YOU CLOSER SHARE
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. HI
THIS IS JONATHAN FELDMAN WITH
THE ARCH STRATEGY BEGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION. WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE SB
NINETY EIGHT I WHICH CONTAINS
THE SAME BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN
APPLIED IN THE PREVIOUS VERSION
SENATE BILL SIX TO NINE FROM
LAST YEAR THAT THE GOVERNOR
VETOED THE THAT STILL GET GOOD
DRAFTING DISCOURAGING. SB
NINETY EIGHT WOULD ALLOW. FROM
NEW SERVICE ONLINE MISTER NEWS.
ALREADY OR TELEVISION STATIONS
ACCESS TO ENCRYPTION THE BILL.
ANY IMMEDIATE AREA SURROUNDING
ANY EMERGENCY FIELD COMMAND
POST. OR ANY OTHER COMMAND POST
PLEASE FIND A ROLLING CLOSURE.
I WITH THAT ACTED AS BEING
NINETY EIGHT ALSO CREATED NEW
PENAL CODE VIOLATION FOR AN
OFFICER WHO INTERFERES WITH OR
OBSTRUCTS. UNDEFINED NEWS
REPORTER. TATIAN OF THAT ANY
ANSWER THAT I'D PENALTY OR OF
THE PENAL CODE COURTS TO. SO BE
OFFICERS WILL FACING CRIMINAL
TRIAL FROM- LEVINE THAT SECTION.
SB NINETY FURTHER. COMPLICATES
AND WITH THE OFF BUT IN THE
NEEDS OF. WE SAW FOR FAILURE
TO. IF EITHER OCCURRED. FOR A
VIOLATION PARAGRAPH ONE OF THE-AND OF SEX ONE FOR EIGHT. AB
FIFTY ONE FOR EIGHT MICEX. IS
WHAT IS TO SOMEONE FOR SURE AND
OR EMERGENCY CARE IN THE DISH
OF THEIR DUTIES- INSTATEMENT
LAST YEAR THERE ARE CAN SOMEHOW
SITE AND REMOVE- NEWS SERVER.
FOR- IN SOME OTHER CODE SECTION
OR ANOTHER- I THANK TO US
BECAUSE AT MY BE AND- MOVING PT
WHY FORTY EIGHT CREATE CONFLICT
ALARM AND CONFUSION IN THE
ABILITY OF THE OFF. ARE
CONCERNED IS THAT ALL ARE
PLACED IN A DITCH WHERE WE CAN
SITE REMOVED. REPORTER EVEN IF
IT'S A- THERE DIDN'T AN
INTERNSHIP POTENTIAL.
VIOLATIONS OF THE PENAL CODE.
IF OBSTRUCT MEDIA REGARDLESS OF
THE OFF TRY TO DO THEIR AND THE
PUBLIC. I HAVE COMMITTEE POST
DURING THESE COULD AND. YOU
KNOW CAN BE OVERWHELMED THE-
AND THERE'S ALSO CA WITH
EXPANDING THAT. MEDIA I'M NOT
MUCH FOR NOW BEHIND. MANY OF
THE NETWORK BUT AND AGENCIES A
FOR. I WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
NEED IMPORTANCE FOR ALLOWING ME
TO ASK THE CUBBIES AND EVENTS I
WANT STATE THAT I THE WAY OF
BLUE AUTHORED TO WORK US ON THE
ISSUE AND HOPEFULLY CAN MORE
TIME THIS YEAR. FINALLY TOOK
THE GOAL OF THE PLEDGE WITH
OBJECTION THREE WOULD BE A ON
THE. WE HAVE JONATHAN BUT THAT
WAS JONATHAN FED. WALDRON IT
WAS OKAY DO WE HAVE SHAUN
RUNDLE. ON THE LINE YEAH CAN
YOU HEAR ME MADAM CHAIR WE AT
WE CAN YES SIR GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- MANAGER MEMBERS SAID
SHAUNA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OR
C. P. O. A. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
THE OFFICE OFFICE WELL FOR NOT
ONLY DISCUSSIONS THIS YEAR BUT
IN TWENTY TWENTY ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE PARTICULARLY IN
THE WAKE OF THE CIVIL UNREST
ISSUES OF THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS. A NON UNION LEADERSHIP.
ASSOCIATION OF MORE THAN TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND COPS WHO WANT TO
BE AND LIED ABOUT COPS. OUR
MEMBERS ARE BOTH SUPERVISORY
AND FRONTLINE OFFICERS RECEIVED
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM WHO
ROUTINELY SET UP COMMAND POSTS
DESCRIBED IN THE BILL BEFORE
YOU TODAY. BECAUSE- MY
COLLEAGUE MR CALL ME JUST
MENTIONED WORDING OF PC FOR
NINE POINT SEVEN. WELL YES IT
DOES REFERENCE AN EMERGENCY
COMMAND POST BUT ALSO SET UP
ANY OTHER COMMAND POST. AT A
DEMONSTRATION MARCH RALLY OR
PROTEST WHERE THE INDIVIDUALS
ARE ENGAGED PRIMARILY AND
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
ACTIVITY SO WHAT THAT MEANS TO
THE GRANTING SO CALLED MEDIA
ACCESS TO SIMULTANEOUS OR
NEARBY COMMAND POST SET UP IN
RESPONSE PERHAPS TO A VIOLENT.
RIOT OR A- UP SO WE'LL JUST.
YOU NEED TO COMMAND BECAUSE A
DRASTICALLY DIFFERENT IN TERMS
OF INFORMATION DISCLOSED SAFETY
PROTOCOL SEVEN PERHAPS AN
EMERGENCY DISCLOSURE- AND FOR
EXAMPLE CONCERN REMAINS
REGARDLESS OF DUTY OPERATOR
DULY AUTHORIZED OR NOT. BE
INTENTIONAL OR UNINTENTIONAL
LEAKING OR AFP OR BROADCASTING
A TACTICAL INFORMATION FROM A
DEMONSTRATION- COMMAND GOES
BACK COULD JEOPARDIZE THE
SAFETY OF OFFICERS. AND
CIVILIANS- B. ACCORDING TO THE
BILL AUTHORITIES ME TO AND
COMMAND CLOSEST WHEN
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN. THAT IS PER
PROTECTED- OBVIOUSLY UNDER THE
FIRST AMENDMENT BUT IT DOES NOT
DISTINGUISH THAT IT IS ONLY
DURING PROTESTS OR
REGISTRATIONS BUT INSTEAD ANY
COMMAND CODES WHERE THERE
HAPPENS TO BE A DEMONSTRATION.
STAR MEMBERS HAVE FEARS OF
PUTTING PEOPLE IN HARM'S WAY BY
ALLOWING ACCESS FOR- TOWARD
PEOPLE CLAIMING TO BE
JOURNALISTS AS WE'VE SEEN IN
OTHER STATES OR INFORMATION
GATHERS BY SIMPLY WATCHING A
BUSINESS CARD. IT'S NOTED IN
PREVIOUS BILL DISCUSSIONS THE
MONUMENTAL TASK OF ENSURING THE
SAFETY OF LARGE NUMBERS OF
DEMONSTRATORS. AND THEN COMING
UP ONLINE FOR SPEND AND- WE
FEEL THAT. WOULD PUT AT RISK
THOSE SAFETY PRECAUTIONS-
THERE'S ALSO NO CLEAR LANGUAGE
ON SETTING A RESTRICTION ON HOW
MANY. HOW MANY SUPERVISORS CAN
BE REQUESTED NOR HOW MANY
CREDENTIALED MEDIA CAN ACCESS
THE COMMAND POST. SO WHILE WE
APPRECIATE. LAST YEAR'S WHOSE
DEFINITION OF DULY AUTHORIZED
ME TO BE REMOVED OUR CONCERN
FOR ME WITH THE FACT THAT OTHER
COMMAND POST SET UP BY THE BILL
WILL BE TWO. MORE HARM THAN
GOOD. AND DESPITE ANYTHING. TO
THE CONTRARY LONG PORTIONS
PRIORITIES ALWAYS THE SAFETY OF
ALL PEOPLE IN ATTENDANCE AT THE
DEMONSTRATION MARC PROTESTER.
OR AT LEAST GIVE ME. BUT IN THE
MIDDLE AT THE JOHN LAST YEAR'S
PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR STRESSED
THAT SETTING UP A COMMAND POST
SHOULDN'T THEN IT BERKELEY
PROVIDE UNFETTERED ACCESS TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMAND CENTER-
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S WILL
BE HERE SB NINETY EIGHT WILL
DO. TRANSPARENCY OF THE PRUDENT
LIMITS AND CERTAIN QUALITY-
TACTICS AND STRATEGY SHOULD BE
SAFEGUARDED THE PLOT FORTUNATE
TO KEEP OUR STRATEGIC ADVANTAGE
IN CONTROLLING. RIOTS AND
PROTESTS AND IN DOING SO
HOLDING THE FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS OF THOSE INVOLVED AND
PROTECTING THE LIVES OF ALL OF
OUR PROTECTING ALL LIFE. AND
PROPERTY THANK YOU MISTER
LANDER. YEAH WE THANK YOUNG
OFFICE D. BUT REQUIRE. MUST IT
THIS TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- LET'S MOVE
TO ANY WITNESSES AND BROUGH
FORTY TWO OR THREE. CENA ARE
THERE ANY WAY IN ROOM. TWENTY
FOUR FORTY WHO WAS TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. NINETY
EIGHT. C. NONE THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINETY
EIGHT WE WILL BE CAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINETY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER IN PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINETY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THERE ARE NOW. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE FIVE PEOPLE IN Q.
ACTUALLY HAVE SIX NOW. PERFECT
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES A CALL THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NUMBER
FORTY FOUR THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I YES THANK
YOU AND I'M SURE THIS IS NOT A
HIGHER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY- IN
OPPOSITION DUE TO THAT NO
WORKABLE DEFINITION OF A DULY
AUTHORIZED PRESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MANAGER MEMBERS RUNNING SHERMAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
LOCATION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
NUMBER FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CORY CELLS
ARE LOW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BLIND NUMBER
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
BRANDON UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE FIND. MY
NUMBER TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
IS OPEN. VENTURE MEMBERS RANDY
CURRY IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HAVE
TRAUMA PORAC IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
THE LINE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES ONE IS OPEN.
WE CAN HEAR YA LOCAL ON THE. A
LEVEL UNDER AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA MATHEMATICAL. IT'S
OPPOSITE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AT THIS TIME MADAM
CHAIR WILL HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE WHO THAT. CAN
YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO BE SURE WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL OF THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES PLEASE. YES YES MADAM
CHAIR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINETY EIGHT POINT. TWO
ONE ZERO ONE ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY AND WE DO HAVE
TWO PEOPLE ADMIT THEM I'M SURE
ONE MOMENT. IN HERE. THANK YOU
LINE UP. BELLI NUMBER DROP.
WAITED FOR ANOTHER NUMBER NINE.
BUT I NUMBER FIFTY SIX WELL I'M
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NOT USE
DOUBLING ON BEHALF OF THE ROCK
WE PROTECTED LEAGUE IS LOCATION
BLOCK AND LOOKED AT EACH YEAR
OF. AN OFF ON THE OPPOSITE END
YOU GOT THAT THE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION THAT THE CAMPUS BUT
PEACOCK H. ALL RIGHT. THANK.
YOU. TOM ADAMS THERE'S NO I
THINK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
FOR THE SUPPORT FOR- THANK YOU
ALL. ARSUF SUPPORT IN OFFICE
WITNESS WE WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE- DO OF
OUR MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR.
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- SENATE
RADFORD THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING THIS ON BEHALF OF MR
REQUIRED- I THINK MANY OF US-
IN WATCHING NEWS REPORTS OF
VARIOUS OF THE EVENTS. THAT
WERE IN RESPONSE TO EITHER THE-
GEORGE FORD INCIDENT OR OTHERS
I THINK WE KIND OF WATCHED IN
HORROR WHERE- WELL EVEN IF WE
TAKE EVEN THE CAPITAL-
INSURRECTION WHERE WE SAW-
LEGITIMATE PRESS REPORTERS
WHETHER TV NEWS WITH CAMERA
OTHERS. IN EFFECT JUST- EITHER-
OF OVERRIDDEN OR OR- ELIMINATED
FROM THE SITE AND JUST LIKE THE
BILL I PRESENTED. INSPERITY IS
VERY IMPORTANT IN DEMOCRACY AND
OUR NEWS REPORTERS YOU KNOW
WHETHER WE AGREE WITH THE NEWS
OR NOT IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PRESENT TO US FULLY AND IF THEY
ARE. INTERFERED WITH IN AT
PROTESTS OR ANY OTHER TYPES OF
EVENTS THEN WE DO NOT GET THAT.
NOW THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT VARIOUS OPPOSITION
REYES THAT PROBABLY THE MEMBER
I'M SURE IT WILL WORK FINE. AND
I WON'T ASK YOU THE QUESTION I
MEAN YOU COURSE COULD ANSWER
HAVE YOU HAVE THE CENTER BUT- I
KNOWING THE AUTHOR. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT THOSE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED THAT DESERVE
TO BE- MODIFIED AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD THAT HE WILL
INTERACT WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND- DO SO APPROPRIATELY IF IT
IS APPROPRIATE. AND SO I AM- IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND MARY
POLICE SAID IT WAS BROUGHT. AND
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I'M
HAPPY TO MAKE A MOTION. THANK
YOU FOR THEIR SKINNER. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR- QUESTIONS
FROM OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
DO HAVE A QUESTION WITH REGARDS
TO- HOW TO BETTER- IDENTIFIED
THE PRESS- THAT'S ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE ARE THERE
ANY THOUGHTS ON HOW THAT WOULD
BE- BE ABLE TO CLARIFY AND MAKE
SURE THAT. IT'S JUST THE
PRESIDENT'S BEING. ALLOWED TO
HAVE ACCESS TO OTHER AREAS. ARE
THE SAME WAY IT'S BEEN DONE FOR
DECADES BY HAVING PROPER PRESS
CREDENTIALS THAT CLEARLY HAS
USUALLY AUTHORIZED BY A LAW
ENFORCEMENT LOCAL JURISDICTION
IT CLEARLY IDENTIFIES THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE SURPRISED
NOTHING CHANGES JUST AS YOU.
HAVE PROCESSES SHOW THEIR ID TO
COMING HERE TO COME TO A NASH
NATURAL OR NATURAL DISASTER THE
SAME WOULD BE FOR MARCH A
PROTESTER ANY OTHER KIND OF
RALEIGH CHAU- THEY FIGURE IT
OUT FOR ANYTHING ELSE SO I
DON'T KNOW WHERE TE CONFUSION
WITH- HAPPENED JUST BECAUSE
IT'S A RALLY OR PROTEST OR
BLACK LIVES MATTER. OR IN THE-
HAVE ASSEMBLED. I'M JUST GONNA
CARRY JUST BECAUSE I KNOW HOW
PEOPLE CAN- FOR DOCUMENTS
FORCES DOCUMENTS AND THAT
THAT'S THE REASON FOR MY
QUESTION IS JUST YOU KNOW HOW
DO WE ASSURE ESPECIALLY SINCE
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THEM.
SPURRED A SPECIAL PRIVILEGE OF
MOVING TO OTHER AREAS FIRST NOT
NOT HAVING TO- HAVING MORE
ACCESS BASICALLY AND SO THAT IS
THE CONCERN IF WE GIVE THEM
MORE ACCESS THAN- HAVE MORE
PRIVILEGE IN THAT IN THAT
RESPECT. AND HOW DO WE ASSURE
AND MAKE. BASICALLY HOW DO WE-
ASSURE THAT THE PAST ARE NOT
BEING FORTUNATE BEING-
DUPLICATED THIS BILL DOESN'T
GRANT ANY MORE PRIVILEGE THAN
ALREADY EXIST UNDER- PINNACLE
FOUR ZERO NINE POINT FIVE ALL
THE STATE'S AS IN A NATURAL
DISASTER USE. ESTABLISH A
DESIGNATED AREA FOR PROCESS FOR
PROTEST RALLY BACK THAT'S ALL
THEY'RE ASKING THE SAME
GUIDELINES THAT ALREADY EXIST
AND WHILE THIS ISN'T EXPAND
UPON ANYTHING SO AGAIN WE CAN
FIGURE IT OUT I THE NOW TO
DISASTER IN AGAIN PRESSER NO
WARM CLAWING TO. GET IN THE
LINE OF FIRE AN ARMY FOOD OR
FAR BUT A PROTEST IN FIGHTING
IN THE SKIRMISHERS GROUND NO
MORE THAN THEY WANT TO BE IN A
LINE OF A NATURAL DISASTER BE
IT A FLOOD OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT THEY WANT TO BE AN
ASSEMBLY DESIGNATED AREA WHERE
THEY CAN REPORT. ALL WHAT'S
GOING ON AND AGAIN THE STORY OF
UNFETTERED ACCESS SYSTEM FOR
THIS THING FROM THE TRUTH THEY
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO A COMMAND
POST OR MOBILE VEHICLE OR-
BEING YOUR- EAVESDROP RANGE OF.
YOU KNOW WHATEVER POLICE
OFFICERS ARE DOING STE CANADA
AS AS A RELATES TO STRATEGY IT
WOULD JUST SAY AGAIN TO ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE A DESIGNATED AREA
TO REPORT FROM A PROTEST. RALLY
OR MARCH. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR BYRD- CONDUCTOR
COMMITTEE START DO WE HAVE ANY
MORE COMMENTS A QUESTION
SENATOR SKINNER NO I WILL MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. SENATOR
BROUGHT FOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
CLOSE YES THANK YOU ON BEHALF
OF CENTER BAR I THINK S. B.
NINETY EIGHT IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE AGAIN IT ALLOWS WHAT WE
ALL VALUE FREEDOM OF THE PRESS
TO ACCURATELY TELL THE STORIES
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THIS. DOES NOT
AFFORD REPORTERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERFERE WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT ANY KIND OF WAY
IT JUST ALLOWS THEM TO DO WHAT
RT AGAIN IN STATUTE AND IT WAS
AGREEMENT- WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO LAST YEAR THAT THEY CAN
COME UP ON THE GREEN AT ALL
WHAT WAS DULY AUTHORIZED MEMBER
OF THE PRESS. THIS NAILS
CLEARLY STATE WHAT'S ALREADY IN
FOR A LEGACY FOUR HUNDRED POINT
I MEAN FOUR HUNDRED AND NINE
POINT FIVE WHICH DULY
AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE PRESS THAT'S WHAT'S ALREADY
THERE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES EIGHT ELIMINATED- THE
MISDEMEANOR AS WELL THERE'S NO.
CHARGER R. OR CRIME ASSOCIATED
FOR POLICE OFFICERS WHO WERE
ARE DOING THEIR JOB SO IT'S NO
ADDITIONAL CRIMES THAT OFFICERS
ARE FEARFUL OF BECAUSE OF THE
CENTURY. FOR MARRIAGE AND I
RESPECT THAT STRUGGLE. THANK
YOU SENATOR PER. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU AND THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR SKINNER-
PLEASE CALL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. B. NINETY EIGHT MCGUIRE
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD I'D CHOKE
ABSTAINED THANKS SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE WIENER. WIENER I'D
THE MOTIONS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS AND ABOUT HIS
THREE TO ZERO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE MOTION IS PASSED AND
IT'S THREE TWO ONE. THANK YOU.
I WILL NOT PASSED THE- YEAH.
WITH A HAMMER. THANK YOU
SENATOR A TO A BLOKE- FOR
SEEKING RECONSIDERATION ON S.
B. SEVENTY THREE- BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED AND NOW WE WILL REVOKE-
DO A REVOTE ON S. B. SEVENTY
THREE- WHAT THE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THIS
MEASURE SB SEVENTY THREE D.
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD
HI ADVERTISEMENT SHOWBOAT. NOW
THIS. THINGS WELL IF I. ONE OF.
NO. THE TERRIBLE NO SKINNER AYE
SKINNER I'D- WIENER WIENER AYE
VOTE IS THREE TO ONE THE BOOK
REFLECTS THREE HIGHS ONE NO ON
S. P. SEVENTY THREE THE MEASURE
PASSES. REMEMBER THAT CONCLUDES
OUR HEARING TODAY OF PUBLIC
SAFETY IF THERE'S NO FURTHER
BUSINESS WE STAND ADJOURNED.